So, ich bin wieder da.
Das mit heute Mittag war recht optimistisch.
Weil Mittag ist seit, sagen wir mal, mindestens vier Stunden rum.
Es ist, ja stimmt, stimmt.
Ich habe nicht mittags gesagt, ich habe gesagt nach dem Mittagessen.
Ich meine, nach dem Mittagessen ist es ja öfters.
So.
Also wenn Teams jetzt schon wieder...
Ne, die Lautstärke ist richtig.
Und ich brauche ein bisschen was Entspannenderes.
Moin.
Ich brauche ein bisschen was Entspannenderes.
Wartet mal.
Ja.
Alles gut.
Exzellent.
So sieht es aus.
So, wisst ihr was?
Wir machen jetzt weiter, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Für alle, die gestern nicht da waren.
Zeige ich euch das mal.
Wir haben gestern ein paar neue Tools ausprobiert.
Und uns nebenbei...
...eine neue Streaming-VM angelegt.
Das ist die alte.
Da werden wir heute sicherlich das ein oder andere noch mal abgucken müssen.
Das ist die, die ich die letzten paar Jahre über verwendet habe.
Aber jetzt gibt es eine neue.
Und da fehlt noch einiges.
Die sieht noch nicht so hübsch aus.
Das Einzige, was tatsächlich ganz gut aussieht, ist, glaube ich, der Prompt.
Der ist schon ganz nice.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, woran es gelegen hat?
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
Ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht noch daran erinnern.
Gestern.
Du kannst den Tab-Style ändern.
Was für ein Tab?
Tab-Style.
Gucken wir mal.
Ach ja, das ist schön.
Das ist schon was gelernt.
Ach, zeige ich mal.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Gibt es da schon irgendwelche...
Gibt es da irgendwelche Presets oder sowas für?
Tab-Bar-Style.
Das ist nicht so ganz synchron hier.
Aber das ist schon okay.
Ich würde mir tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr...
...ein bisschen mehr Border wünschen hier unten drum.
Man erkennt das.
Ganz gut.
Das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Wir müssen am Terminal müssen wir auch noch ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Und...
Wir müssen jedes Mal die Statusleiste müssen wir noch machen.
Ordentliche Icons hinzufügen und sowas.
Es gibt schon noch ein paar Sachen, die wir machen müssen.
Also da wird einiges machen.
So, also.
Ich zeige euch mal, wo ganz gelegen hat.
Ihr erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch dran,
dass das Terminal gestern aus mir nicht wirklich verständlichen Gründen gelaggt hat.
Und zwar, wenn ich eine Weile hier einfach nur Enter gedrückt habe und dann losgelassen habe.
Ihr seht jetzt, es ist instant, instant.
Hat es noch vier, fünf Sekunden nachgeleckt.
Da war irgendwo was, war irgendwo was verkehrt.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, woran das, woran das gelegen hat.
Ähm...
Wie ist das?
Color...
Gleich...
Irgendwie sowas.
Oder nehmen wir mal das Default, die Default-Colors ist auch egal.
Guckt mal Leute, es laggt wieder.
Seht ihr?
Ich sage euch, wenn ich den Knopf loslasse,
Jetzt.
Und jetzt ist es fertig.
Habt ihr es gesehen, wie es laggt?
Und das liegt daran,
sobald ich ein Color scheme,
Guckt jetzt nicht schnell.
Achtung, ich lasse jetzt.
Instant.
Also, die haben irgendeinen Bug.
Sobald ein Color scheme gesetzt ist,
dann laggt das.
Ich habe die Vermutung,
dass die das hinter der Haube nicht cachen,
sondern jedes Mal neu von der Platte einlesen.
Bei jedem Mal Enter drücken.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Ich verstehe es zumindest nicht.
Zumindest Color scheme ist langsam.
Wir können ja mal kurz bei dem Kerl auf GitHub gucken,
ob das dazu vielleicht schon was gibt.
Kann ich die Playlist mal please entscheiden,
ob sie laut oder leise sein will?
Wir gucken mal kurz in den Issues,
ob da irgendwas drin ist.
Alter, 251 von Kanarski.
Na gut, das ist halt ein Eintrag in der Config.
Laggy Tab Repainting.
Lag.
Muss ich mal nach Lag suchen?
Lag Issues.
Lag. Where is that?
Laggie.
Lag.
CPU Usage.
Performance Usage.
Es liegt übrigens auf jeden Fall nicht an den Farben
findet man nix zu.
Hätte jetzt gedacht vielleicht in Kombination Lag.
hätte jetzt gedacht vielleicht in Kombination Lag.
Äh.
Also wie gesagt, wenn Color scheme gesetzt ist,
das team gesetzt ist wir sortieren das ganze mal noch nach neuesten legge ich
bist du auf dem main branche ist eine gute frage
nee ich bin auf dem letzten release branche hier guck mal ich bin auf dem
letzten release branche ich bin auf november 2022 das ist von gestern ach
guck mal da legge tab repay nehmen mac ja dass das habe ich schon gab es doch
was anderes oder das ist das doch ist das habe ich eben ja auch gerade
gefunden aber das scheint mir also das ist das issue hier wir können es
ausprobieren ob es auf dem main gefixt ist was mal aufgucken wie wir gucken
mal ja aber das scheint mir doch was anderes zu sein
wayland bsp ok das ist x es ist x hier piekos war auch noch machen dass wir ein
bisschen bisschen transparenz haben akku man hat ein video
ok
, ok zeige uns mal zeige uns mal das gelecke auch kommt man kann sogar icons
in den tabs haben und das ist das brauche ich jetzt in tabs
sau will er den wird er den autor flamen oder ist das ab das ist keine
absicht sau 234 erscheint ich glaube das ist was anderes ich glaube das ist was
anderes
zumindest ich habe festgestellt am colors game liegt es nicht also an den farben
selbst liegt es nicht weil guckt jetzt sich schnell ja bin ich korrekt nicht
ähnlich drei konflikt editieren hier und sobald ich in class game rein machen
laggys er jetzt man sieht ja auch schon mal im ender drücken wie sehr das
hinterher legt ja und jetzt zack und kaum mache ich das raus kaum mache ich das aus
es wieder super fast.
Man sieht es ja auch leider schon beim Enter drücken.
Also es könnte, es könnte vielleicht
wirklich der gleiche, der gleiche
Bug sein.
Wir können mal, wir können mal tatsächlich,
wir können mal
tatsächlich den
neuesten Master installieren.
Ich finde es sehr nice, dass der verschiedene
Icons hier oben hat und sowas.
Ich muss mir unbedingt die Config abgucken
von manchen Leuten.
Da kann man wirklich cooles Zeug machen.
Gibt glaube kein Nightly-Build. Doch, gibt es.
Sieht zumindest so aus.
This should be fixed in main.
Doch, hier, guck, da.
Also man muss es selbst kompilieren
nochmal in das Bash. Das wird ja nicht so schwierig
sein. Also, nennen wir mal das.
Ach, jetzt muss man doch Rust installieren.
Ah, okay.
Meinetwegen.
Yes.
Dann installieren wir mal die neueste,
naja, dann installieren wir mal die neueste
Version.
Das ist von Main Branch.
Die Git-Repos sind immer von Main Branch.
Also, meistens.
Zu 99%.
Das ist einfach das Neueste, das Neueste,
der Neueste Master-Stand,
der da genommen wird.
Die Rust-Installation
in Blazingly Fast, aber
bilden von Rust-Programmen ist nicht unbedingt Blazingly Fast.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Lassen wir, installieren wir doch mal
die neueste Version von dem Terminal
und gucken, ob es immer noch laggy ist.
Lag AF. Das Problem ist,
also, es ist gar kein
großartiges Problem,
weil ich will eh das Farbschema
anpassen. Also kann ich eh kein Preset
nehmen. Ich will eh ein paar Sachen von Hand
anpassen. Also insofern ist es nicht
wirklich schlimm, dass es
so nicht funktioniert.
Alter, Free-Type!
Was zum Teufel lädt er sich da alles runter?
Will der jetzt auch noch Free-Type? Okay.
Okay, wir sehen uns in zwei Stunden wieder.
Naja, gut.
Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht, weil ich
meine, ich habe halt einfach mal acht Kerne da drin.
Das sollte ganz gut flutschen.
Ach, was gibt's?
Schöneres Sonntagabend, 18.50 Uhr.
Erstmal eine Runde Placingly Fast
written in Rust zu kompilieren.
Oh, jetzt hat er aber den Turbo eingelegt hier.
Source is ready.
Building.
700.
Acht Kerne.
Alter.
Leck, der Stream.
Das Ding haut aber mal richtig rein, Alter.
Ey.
Das Ding lastet ja fast so viel aus
wie Prime 95, Alter.
Das sind 13.900k
und es ist erstmal acht Kurs
voll mit Kompilieren. Easy.
Es ist aber halt
Placingly Fast written in Rust.
Da gibt's nix.
Ne, die haben keine Daily Builds,
so wie's aussieht. Die haben Releases?
Tags? Könnte man halt gucken.
Nö.
Die scheinen keine Daily Builds oder sowas
zu haben. Nö.
Aber vielleicht
vielleicht auch Flatpack.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
who cares?
Ach doch, Nightly App Image.
Könnte man auch machen.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Wir könnten auch ein Nightly Build.
Wir könnten auch ein Nightly Build nehmen.
Egal, wir machen selbst ein Bild.
Guck mal, ist auch fast schon fertig kompiliert.
Daku, dankeschön für den Zap.
Ich hab's übrigens
gar, hat überhaupt keinen Sound gemacht.
Gerade.
Lip SSH, Alter.
Der kompiliert echt das halbe Internet.
Hypergachi wird auch kompiliert.
Ist das extra,
aktuell.
Ich glaub, der Rechner leckt gerade ein bisschen,
weil er ausgelastet ist.
Ach so, die Uhrzeit könnte auch sein.
Das ist, das ist Default, die Default
i3-Statusbar.
Die ist richtig
minimalistisch.
Die kommt auch noch weg.
Erstens sieht die hässlich as fuck aus.
Und das schützt, glaube ich, keine Transparenz.
Und, naja, die Anzeige ist auch gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Ihr habt recht.
So, passt schon.
Ne, wir machen nicht i3-Status-Rust.
Wir probieren Bumblebeamer aus.
Guck, immer mal ein bisschen paar neue Sachen testen.
Viel Slack, man.
Wie das einfach...
Hättet ihr gedacht, dass das beim Kompilieren
wirklich einfach jetzt die komplette CPU auslastet
von, für das Terminal?
Das hätt ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Mein Rust ist ja bekannt dafür,
dass das irgendwie 30 Milliarden Abhängigkeiten
kompilieren...
Passt auf, jetzt, jetzt ein Fehler.
Passt auf, jetzt ein Fehler.
Jetzt ein Compiler-Fehler beim letzten,
beim letzten Build-Step.
Das wird mich nicht wundern.
Kannst du nehmen, i3 noch eine andere.
Der i3 ist ja nur der Window-Manager.
Du kannst, du kannst Ubuntu nehmen in der VM
und i3 installieren, ist auch kein Problem.
Oder du nimmst Xfce oder Mint.
Mint mit Mate, find ich auch ganz nice, in der, in der VM.
Wenn man was Fertiges haben will.
Remove western, yes.
Yes.
So, jetzt machen wir das Terminal auf und machen das Terminal, ok,
Ne, das ist aber die neueste Version.
Hat das sowas wie Minus-Minus-Version vielleicht?
Aha.
2023, 01, 21, 18 Uhr, 24, 29.
Ja, alles.
Ne, ist das überhaupt 18?
Ist das überhaupt 18 Uhr 24?
Ne, ich mein.
Wann hatten der Dude zuletzt committed?
Vor 16 Stunden?
Ne, nicht so ganz.
Na doch.
Ne.
Ach, was auch immer.
Also das hier hinten ist auf jeden Fall der Comet-Hash.
Was das hier sein soll, weiß ich gar nicht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht die Patch-Version, auch nicht Comet seit letztem Tag.
Weil Comet seit letztem Tag wären ein bisschen viele.
Na gut, also schauen wir mal, ob der Fehler jetzt behoben ist.
Ob es jetzt noch blazingly faster ist.
Weil written in Rust ist es ja eh schon.
Das kann er...
Leute, das geht eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich kann das nicht langsam sein.
Easy, ist gefixt.
Ist gefixt.
Im neuesten Master.
Funzt.
Ist funzt, Leute.
Im neuesten Master ist es...
Okay, nice.
Gut.
Wir kommen hier das trotzdem wieder aus, weil...
Ich will ja mein eigenes Farbschema haben.
Schau mal, was die geändert haben.
Wahrscheinlich jede Menge seit...
Ich mein, der letzte Tag war im November.
Also ich würde jetzt...
Ich würde jetzt ungern hier durchscrollen bis November und durchgucken.
Also ich vermute mal, die haben irgendwas geändert wie das Parsing.
Ich hab was mit Parsing gesehen, ne, okay.
Irgendwas Theme oder Color, irgendwas mit Color.
Nee, ach, keine Ahnung.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Zumindest, das ist gefixt.
Das ist jetzt blazingly fast wieder alles.
Es geht weiter.
Ja, ich habe aber erst angefangen vor zehn Minuten oder so.
Gut, also jetzt haben wir einen Terminal schnell.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, Leute.
Ähm, ich werde das wieder, ich werde das...
Wir haben es, wir haben es zwar...
Wir haben es zwar selbst kompiliert, ich werde das aber wieder aninstallen.
Und das normale installieren.
Weil ich keinen Bock habe auf jedes Mal Git-Build.
Sobald es ein Update gibt.
Also wir nehmen jetzt lieber das normale, das ist auch schnell genug.
Was ist der Plan?
Wir richten heute die Linux-VM weiter ein und probieren weiter neue Sachen aus.
So, also jetzt ist mein Terminal wieder schön schnell.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich habe mir was überlegt.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Absolut Sixthead.
Da hat mich heute Morgen der Chat auf die Idee gebracht.
Also ich meine...
Es muss ja Sixthead sein, wenn der Chat mich auf die Idee gebracht hat.
Weil hat der Chat schon jemals irgendwas auch nur im Ansatz vorgeschlagen, was nicht Absolut Next Level High IQ ist.
Kann mich nicht erinnern.
Kommt eigentlich nicht vor.
Und...
So, Nightly, Nightly Build.
So, und zwar...
Ähm...
Es gibt doch...
Immer das Problem...
Dass, wenn man Caps drückt...
Oh, gehe ich jetzt eigentlich raus, muss ich sagen.
Wenn man Caps Lock drückt aus Versehen, dann schreibt man groß.
Und niemand braucht die Caps Lock Taste.
So, und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe, was doch richtig praktisch wäre, wenn man Caps Lock einfach als Copy verwenden könnte.
Als Copy Knopf.
Und das muss, soweit ich das gesehen habe, in der Terminal Config relativ easy sein.
Also man kann zum Beispiel, wenn man nämlich hier mal nach Caps sucht.
Caps.
Caps Lock.
Dann findet man zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Und bla bla bla bla.
Wo Caps Lock disabled ist.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man das hier setzt.
Caps und Escape.
Ne, habe ich schon probiert, mag ich nicht.
Habe ich schon vor einer ganzen Weile mal ausprobiert.
Das mag ich nicht.
So, und jetzt kann man zum Beispiel sagen...
Ähm...
Moment, Copy...
Copy To brauche ich.
Copy To.
Genau.
Das hier brauche ich jetzt.
Keys.
Und jetzt müsste ich, wenn das...
Wenn das funktioniert...
In meinem Terminal einstellen können.
Gehen wir mal hier.
Hier rein, da sind wir stehen geblieben.
Also, das habe ich übrigens gestern noch eingefügt.
Kann ich euch auch noch zeigen.
Gestern noch nach dem Stream hier unten diese...
Die Mappings.
So, und jetzt müsste ich hier eintragen mit dem Key.
Und wie war das, was man eintragen muss?
Was mit Void?
Weil, man weiß nicht warum, aber...
Genau.
So.
Und jetzt...
Kann ich einstellen, Key, Void Symbol, Mods machen wir weg, Copy To, Clipboard.
So, und wenn das jetzt funktioniert...
Also, Caps Lock ist jetzt Disabled.
Aber ich kann jetzt mit Caps Lock Copy machen.
Also, ich klicke jetzt mal an.
Caps und einfügen.
Funst.
Leute.
Ich habe jetzt Caps Lock als Steuerung C-Ersatz.
Was super praktisch ist im Terminal.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich mich daran gewöhne.
Aber der Chat hat heute Morgen eine wirklich gute Idee gehabt.
Ähm.
Weil, im Terminal kannst du kein Ctrl-C drücken.
Und Shift-Ctrl-C finde ich nervig.
Also, ich werde zwei Sachen probieren.
Einmal Copy auf Caps Lock.
Mal gucken, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Nee, ZSH ist schon eine Serie, aber noch nicht eingerichtet.
Also, Copy auf Caps Lock und...
Dann brauche ich noch Maus-Bindings fürs Terminal.
Maus-Bindings.
Und da habe ich schon was vorbereitet.
Oder System-Wide Caps zu Copy-Key machen.
Nee, das wiederum will ich nicht.
Das ist dann wirklich was Terminal-Eigenes jetzt.
Das finde ich schon ganz gut.
Im restlichen System soll es wahrscheinlich eher gar nichts machen.
Weil, da kann man nämlich Ctrl-C drücken.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau.
Also, ich wusste, ich habe den...
Das tut mir wirklich ein bisschen leid.
Ich habe den die ersten 15 Minuten, wo ich dieses Terminal ausprobiert habe,
habe ich den ein bisschen schlecht geredet.
Weil, es halt wirklich scheiß Default-Settings hat.
Aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen, es ist das beste Terminal,
was ich die letzten Jahre über so ausprobiert habe.
Du kannst alles konfigurieren, was du willst.
Und du hast dann Features, richtig coole Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, ihr wisst, ich habe sonst immer T-Max verwendet.
Habe ich jetzt übrigens gar nicht mehr erzählt.
Guck mal, ich kann jetzt einfach Ctrl-2 drücken und er splittet.
Ich kann Ctrl-Prozent drücken und er splittet.
Ich kann Arrow-Keys haben und durch die Teile switchen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie T-Max, nur ohne, dass man T-Max braucht.
Ich kann...
Ah, das habe ich noch nicht.
Das habe ich glaube ich noch nicht belegt.
Dass man zoomen kann.
Dass man zoomen kann, dass man ein Paint groß machen kann.
Das müssen wir auch noch.
Sekunde.
Wobei, warte mal. Ich habe mir doch irgendwas rauskopiert.
Ups. Geil, jetzt habe ich zugemacht.
Ich habe mir doch irgendwas rauskopiert,
was ich hier reinhauen wollte.
Moment, wo habe ich es denn?
Wo ist mein Text? Wo ist mein Text-File?
Ähm...
Das, ne.
Hier, das da brauche ich.
Ja, das müsste funktionieren.
So. Und jetzt...
Kann ich...
Split... Split...
Splitten... Splitten horizontal...
Vertikal. Dann kann ich hier oben
hingehen. Es laggt.
Oh, ne. Vodafone, please.
Ne, es laggt überhaupt nichts.
Vodafone hat nicht...
Hat nicht verkackt.
Laggt nicht.
So. Und jetzt...
Jetzt kann ich oben hingehen. Jetzt drücke ich
die Steuerung F und er maximiert
diesen Tab.
Wobei Tab ist nicht das falsche Wort.
Dieses Panel.
Also er zoomt ran.
Und der große Vorteil...
Bestimmt ist das aber keine Session,
zu der man Disconnecten connecten kann.
Doch! Das geht auch.
Das habe ich aber noch nicht gecheckt.
Das geht auch.
Das Ding kann im Hintergrund weiterlaufen.
Über irgendeinen Socket. Das geht auch.
Das kann alles hier irgendwie. Immer wenn ich mich frage,
kann es das doch?
Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Deswegen sage ich,
das ist das coolste Terminal, was ich seit langem ausprobiert habe.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Lokal ist es jetzt ja auch nicht
so wichtig, dass es weiterlaufen bleibt.
Wann startest du mal einen Desktop neu und willst,
dass was weiterläuft? Das kommt doch relativ selten vor.
Wo es wichtig ist, dass ich ein Terminal
habe, was gut mit T-Max über
SSH funktioniert. Also nicht wie Kitty, was dann wohl
irgendwelche Anzeigeprobleme hat.
Jetzt kann ich reinzoomen. Und was auch deutlich
praktischer ist, was
ich richtig, was ich richtig, wie sagt man so schön
heute, was ich so richtig feier.
Kannst du nochmal den Namen sagen?
Vest Terminal.
Oder Vets. Vets Term.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher Vest Term.
Bei dir kackt ständig der Desktop
ab. Das hatte ich noch nie. Ich weiß nicht, was du da eingestellt hast.
Aber gut, dann ist es natürlich sinnvoll.
Aber das geht damit auch. Das geht damit auch.
So. Und jetzt kommt's.
Und jetzt kommt's. Jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Der Chat hat mich abgelenkt.
Ähm.
Muss mich der Chat auch wieder. Ah ja, ich weiß es wieder.
Ich weiß es wieder. Was viel cooler ist.
Was viel cooler ist.
Man kann jetzt.
Und das geht in T-Max nicht so ohne weiteres.
Guck mal. Mal angenommen, ich möchte
mir jetzt. Patz. Ich möchte jetzt
Zeilen rauskopieren.
In T-Max kannst du nicht gescheit
Scrollback Buffer kopieren.
Also das geht, aber ist relativ umständlich.
Und mit Maus und Tastatur geht's
dann nicht über mehrere Seiten hinweg. Was du hier machen
kannst ist. Erstmal sagst du, ah ja,
gut. Ich will hier 20 Zeilen
rauskopieren. Guck mal da.
Guck mal da.
Also du kannst, du kannst
die Maus ordentlich verwenden.
Da drin. Das kannst du in T-Max
vergessen. Und
du kannst das Mausrad verwenden.
Du kannst ganz normal Terminal Copy
Pasten, so wie es sein soll.
Und wenn du was sehen willst, was du machst, drückst
einfach Steuerung F. Zoomst ran.
Scrollst mit dem Mausrad
dahin, wo du es haben willst und sagst, ach ja Chat.
Ich wollte euch jetzt schon immer mal die ganze
Zeit das hier kopieren. Und dann drückst du
wirklich die Copy Taste und zack.
Ich zeig's euch mal.
Wim aufmachen. Einfügen.
Zack. Habe ich das im Clipboard
gehabt. Das ist unglaublich
praktisch. Viel besser, als wenn das in einem
T-Max läuft. Geht über mehrere
Seiten weg, indem man scrollt, während man
die Maus gedrückt hält. Ja. Das meine ich ja.
Guck. Du kannst hier unten. Du kannst
hier unten. Du kannst sogar mit dem Mausrad scrollen.
Du kannst hier unten anfangen.
Und du gehst dann hoch.
Du gehst dann hoch.
Hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch. Und du siehst,
es ist immer noch alles. Also ich habe jetzt die Maustaste
nicht mehr gedrückt. Und du siehst,
es ist immer noch alles selected.
Und das kann ich jetzt kopieren.
Das kannst du in T-Max komplett
vergessen. Nein. Das geht nicht.
Was du in T-Max machen kannst,
ist, du kannst den Scrollback Buffer öffnen.
Und im Scrollback Buffer
per Tastatur
eventuell mit wackeliger Maus
Unterstützung den
Selection Mode anmachen. Das ist aber
nicht zu vergleichen mit, du kannst einfach
reinklicken und wie in einem ordentlichen Texteditor
scrollen mit dem Mausrad und selecten.
Das ist in T-Max viel, viel umständlicher.
Das ist mega nice.
Also das gefällt mir wirklich gut.
Also das hat wirklich, das Terminal hat wirklich Pluspunkte
gesammelt bei mir. Ich bin wirklich
begeistert davon, wie nice das
funktioniert. So. Und jetzt müssen wir noch
eine Sache machen. Eins ist mir aufgefallen.
Übrigens, das mit dem Caps Lock
ist doch eine dumme Idee.
Ich will eigentlich gar nicht Caps Lock kopieren.
Mir ist gerade eingefallen.
Der Chat hatte zwar eine schlaue Idee, aber ich glaube,
ich will gar nicht Caps Lock kopieren.
Wie gesagt, lieber rechte Maustaste kopieren.
Bei mir geht es genauso, wie es geht
mit T-Max. Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Fake News.
Außer wenn man die Selection weggeht, wenn man die Maus
kopiert. Ach, das ist dieser eklige
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist
Müll. Das ist dieser eklige Maus Mode,
den Wim auch hat, wo man gar nicht
mehr richtig reinklicken kann und die Sachen nicht richtig
kopiert. Nee, nee, das ist
Müll. Wenn du nämlich
reinklickst, kopiert er dann nicht über das
Terminal, sondern kopiert immer in diesem Select
Mode. Dann kannst du dann zum Beispiel nicht
solche Sachen machen wie Doppelklick für
ein Wort, Tripleklick für ganze
Zeile und sowas und
dann weiter
oder so. Das funktioniert nicht
gescheit. Man kann sogar, guck mal, man kann
sogar Block Select hier drin machen. Das ist mega nice.
Finde ich
wirklich gut gemacht. So.
Was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Ah ja, genau.
Es gibt eine Sache. Ich möchte
eigentlich mit meiner rechten Maustaste
kopieren und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Das habe ich mir auch schon mal raus,
habe ich? Moment, irgendwo müsste ich es haben.
Wo ist es?
Ja, hier. Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Für Maus,
ach fuck, wie fügt man überhaupt Mausevents
ein? Ich habe mir jetzt, Leute, ich habe mir nur
das hier, ich habe mir nur das hier rauskopiert.
Das ist aber falsch. Wie macht
man denn, wie macht man denn jetzt Maus, Mausevents?
Mausbindings. Okay,
so. Mausbindings?
So, Mausbindings
Mausbindings
So, und jetzt kann
ich rechtsklicken. Das ist genau das, was ich
haben will. Oh, was habe ich
vergessen? Ah, ich habe ein
Komma, glaube, vergessen. Guck mal, da zeigt
dir sogar, wo du Syntaxprobleme hast.
So, und jetzt
passt mal auf, jetzt kann ich
genauso, jetzt kann ich das genauso benutzen, wie ich
haben will. Rechtsklick,
also markieren,
mit zweimal doppel, also
linker Maustaste markieren,
rechte Maustaste kopieren und
mittlere Maustaste einfügen.
Das ist genau das,
beziehungsweise mittlere Maustaste im
Terminal, ja, ansonsten, ansonsten ist
ja mittlere Maustaste, wenn du es noch selected hast,
das funktioniert ja auch. Du kannst es ja hier machen und
dann direkt einfügen, das funktioniert natürlich auch.
Aber so kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel
anklingen, in Buffer
zum Browser rübergehen und hier reinkopieren.
Das ist genau das, wie ich das haben will
zum, zum Kopieren im Terminal.
Auswählen, rechte Maustaste,
hier reingehen, ups, jetzt war ich aus,
hier reingehen und
einfügen.
So, das ist exzellent.
Jetzt habe ich bloß noch ein anderes Problem und ich glaube,
das muss man eklig machen.
Ich lade das alles hoch, ja.
Bei Putty
braucht man nur markieren und das ist ja Zwischenlage.
Ja, das sackt aber. Das,
das ist Mist, weil
ich kann es dir gar nicht genau sagen. Ich hatte da mit
Putty immer Probleme,
dass beim Maustasten loslassen es
kopiert war.
Es hat, ich kann es dir nicht,
ich kann es dir nicht gescheit sagen, warum.
Es war auf jeden Fall nicht schön.
Also ich finde dieses, so, genau so muss es sein.
Du klickst was an
und dann passiert gar nichts
und erst wenn du eine Copy-Taste
drückst, kopiert das.
Icefreak und Moritz, dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, Icefreak, 32 Monate.
Massive Subscription.
Wilder Igel, dankeschön.
Eine Milliarde Bits. Pog.
Michael, 50 Billiarden ist auch am Start.
Das ist vor allem bei Workstation 17.
Ja, ich habe geupgradet.
Mit einem Key von
Shady Key
Verkäuferseite.
Aber billig, billig.
Kann man auch eine Scrollback Persistent
schaffen? Ich restore immer meine Teamwork Session.
Nachdem ich meine,
das weiß ich nicht, das müssen wir tatsächlich
mal gucken.
So, ein
Problem, was mir nicht gefällt,
gibt es aber immer noch und dann können wir, das ist glaube ich
das letzte, was wir im Terminal machen müssen, aber ich glaube,
das wird eklig zu fixen.
Und zwar,
dieses, das Terminal unterstützt mehrere
Klickreihenfolgen.
Also du kannst
mappen, Tastendruck,
Single-Click,
Double-Click, Triple-Click
und theoretisch geht das bis unendlich
viel Klick. Also du kannst zum Beispiel, du kannst dir so eine
Streak angeben, da kannst du quasi
den, da kannst du den Button für
unterschiedliche Sachen mappen, je nachdem wie oft
du klickst. Also sprich,
Doppel-Click macht was anderes wie Triple-Click,
macht was anderes wie Vierfach-Click und sowas.
Das hat aber einen Nachteil, das hat aber
einen Nachteil. Guckt mal, ich zeige euch
den Nachteil. Ich kopiere jetzt das Wort
WHAT und jetzt will ich das einfügen
mit mittlerer Maustaste.
Guckt mal, funktioniert
wunderbar, einfügen mit
mittlerer Maustaste, aber
guckt mal, was passiert, wenn ich die Maustaste schnell
drücke. Gar nichts.
Einmal, ich drücke jetzt die ganze
Zeit die Maustaste, einmal, weil
der Streak-Counter hochzählt.
Das ist keine Aktion, der zählt, der ist jetzt beim
Streak-Counter bei 85 oder so.
Und erst wenn ich kurz loslasse und wieder anfange
langsam zu drücken, dann
das ist kein JSON, das ist Lua.
Das ist eine Lua-Config.
Deswegen können wir dort auch Sachen machen,
wie wir jetzt machen werden. Passt mal auf.
Mir fällt
nichts besseres ein.
Aber wir können,
guckt mal, hier kann man noch so einen Streak.
Also was ich machen will, ist folgendes.
Das habe ich mir auch schon mal raus,
das habe ich mir auch schon vorbereitet. Moment, wo ist es?
Hier. Also was wir machen wollen,
ist ja folgendes.
Ähm, ne.
Das wollen wir nicht machen.
Wo ist es denn? Ja, ich habe es,
ich habe es nicht. Also im Prinzip wollen wir
sowas hier machen. Guckt, wir wollen
sagen,
ähm,
der mittlere Knopf
soll nicht Clipboard Primary
Selection machen, sondern es soll
Paste Primary Selection
machen. Paste,
Paste, Alter,
ich muss meine Maus irgendwie proppen.
So, das soll Paste Primary Selection
machen, ne.
Paste Primary Selection.
Wenn ich jetzt die mittlere Maustaste drücke, kopiert er.
Und jetzt
will ich das für mehrere Streaks anlegen.
Also für einen Tastendruck, zwei
Tastendrücke, drei Tastendrücke, dass ich
so schnell wie ich will die mittlere Maustaste
drücken kann und alles ist gut.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, das geht,
aber ich habe es nicht gefunden,
dass man einstellt,
wie lang
in Millisekunden quasi die Klick-Events
sind, ja.
Also,
das gibt es leider nicht.
Dann sagt er gleich hier Error.
Geht nicht.
Und, ähm, also
wenn ich hier 1 reinschreibe, ist kein Problem, dann
funktioniert es, ja.
Ähm, sowas
wie Streaks 0
können wir mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht geht ja Streaks
0.
Wartet mal.
Nee, Streaks 0 bringt auch nix.
Minus,
Minus 1? Vielleicht Minus 1?
Probieren wir mal ausprobieren. Minus 1?
Oh, nee, nee, nee. Out of Range.
Out of Range.
Oh, wir sind ja
in Lua. Lull. Das wird wahrscheinlich...
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Wrong.
Ähm, Streak weglassen geht übrigens
auch nicht. Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Das mag er auch nicht.
Also,
entweder kann man irgendwie einstellen, dass
es für den mittleren Mausbutton keine Streaks
gibt. So irgendwie Buttonconfig
oder sowas.
Irgendwas mit Maus.
Oder, wir machen ne Schleife.
Was ist das für ne Müll... Das ist Lua.
Wir machen ne Schleife
und in die Schleife lassen wir einfach hochzählen
bis 99.
Und legen einfach das Mausmapping für 99
an. Da haben wir den Vorteil,
dass es... Vielleicht kann man hier
irgendwie once...
Also, ich finde da jetzt nichts
besseres. So, und deswegen
wisst ihr, was wir machen könnten?
Was tatsächlich ein Vorteil ist davon,
dass das ne komplette Programmiersprache ist.
Wir könnten jetzt sowas machen.
Ihr guckt mal. Licht...
Was?
Kann man da mit Callbacks arbeiten? Vielleicht.
Hast du inzwischen deine Arbeit gewechselt?
Nee, am 1.4.
Als Overwatch 2 released wurde, meintest du, dass
dies auch eine Suche...
...
Was? Meintest du, dass dies auch
Nummer 1 Suche auf Pornhub
wäre? Wie kommt das?
Wie das kommt? Weil die Leute
auf Overwatch Porn stehen.
Ist doch immer so. Es kommt... Du willst gar
nicht wissen... Fragt bitte
nicht, woher ich das weiß. Du willst gar
nicht wissen, was in der Valorant
Szene abgeht. Bei solchen
Geschichten, Leute.
Kann man nicht mehr anziehen machen.
Das ist doch normal. Es kommt
irgendwas raus und die Leute
googeln als erstes, beziehungsweise
suchen erstmal auf Pornhub,
ob es dazu was gibt.
Es ist doch logisch, warum das so kommt.
Das ist... Wie war das? Das Internet ist
verboren.
Also, das ist doch logisch,
dass die danach suchen. Das ist das erste, was ich
erwartet hätte. Kannst du mitnehmen?
Ja. Ja, das habe ich jetzt...
Das habe ich ja auch vor.
Kannst du mitnehmen? Kannst du eingeben auf
neuen PC?
Du kannst sogar den gleichen Key auf
beiden PCs gleichzeitig verwenden.
Habe ich mit VR16 bei der Installation
gemacht. So, weiter.
Also, das funktioniert
nicht. So, und ich habe mir jetzt
folgendes überlegt, was wir machen
können. Und zwar, wir machen eine Schleife.
Also, äh...
Fuck, wir sehen den Lua.
Lua For Loop.
Wie sieht eine Schleife in Lua aus?
Nein. Ach, nicht Lua. Lua.
Lumeric.
Loops in Lua.
Okay, excellent.
Das will ich haben. Außer, dass ich jetzt geblendet
bin. So.
A gleich... Machen wir mal I.
A gleich 1 bis
100.
Do. Print.
Okay, Print will ich auf jeden
Fall nicht doen.
So.
Und jetzt brauche
ich sowas hier. Table.
Nehmen wir das mal irgendwie...
Maus...
Mausbindings.
Kann man das so doppelt
anlegen? Muss mal gucken.
Mausbindings. Jetzt muss man sowas hier
machen. Das weiß ich, weil Lua steht auf so
komische... Sag mal.
Was ist das?
Sag mal, seht ihr das auch? Oder...
Bin ich... Guck ich Shep?
Die Klammern sind nicht
gleich auf.
Okay, ich guck Shep. Das war wohl nur
auf meiner Schriftgröße.
Guck mal, die Klammern sind nicht gleich auf.
Seht ihr das? Auf meiner Schriftgröße
sind die Klammern nicht in der gleichen
Zeile. MonkaS.
Jetzt ist es okay. Guck mal, es ist nur auf
meiner Schriftgröße.
Überall anders.
Überall anders ist top in Ordnung.
Aber nur auf meiner Schriftgröße ist es
broken. Alles okay.
Ich habe exakt die Schriftgröße getroffen,
wo es broken ist. Das ist bestimmt
irgendeine Anti-Alazing-Geschichte,
die verkackt.
Mausbindings.
So, da kommt jetzt...
Gehen wir hier fort.
So, in die Mausbindings kommt jetzt schon mal
das Default-Ding rein, was ich immer
schon gemacht habe.
So, okay.
Wunderbar.
Kein Syntax-Fehler, kein Syntax-Fehler.
Excellent. Und jetzt will ich
irgendwas hier anhängen,
weil ich noch nichts anderes drauf habe.
Lua Append.
How do I
append to a table in Lua?
Ne, so schauen wir nicht.
Wo ist mein Darkreader?
Frontfinder. Brauche ich nicht mehr.
Plugins.
Engines.
Hatte ich kein Darkreader? Ne, ich hatte
gar kein Darkreader installiert.
Ich habe Firefox auf Dark Theme umgestellt,
was aber alleine ja nicht
reicht, weil
es nur bei Seiten geht, die was anbieten.
Da ist so viel, viel, viel,
viel schöner.
Viel exzellenter.
Versuchen wir mal ein bisschen ran,
dass man was sieht.
Das können wir wieder aninstallen. Remove Extension.
Ja.
Extension is removed.
Also wie konnte man das? Table insert.
Ja.
Richtig Skandal. Warum hat es der Gopherflow
eigentlich keinen Darkmode? Also sowas
brauchen wir jetzt hier. Table insert
in die Table.
Mausbindings.
Wenn man das jetzt so richtig schreiben
kann. Mausbindings
will ich einfügen.
Was will ich in die Table
Mausbindings einfügen?
Das da, oder?
Das da.
So.
So müsste das eigentlich funktionieren.
Hoffentlich habe ich keinen Syntaxfehler produziert.
Okay, sieht nicht so aus.
Nice, nice, nice.
Und jetzt sagen wir Streak.
Streak ist i.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Und jetzt sagen wir Mausbindings
gleich
Mausbindings.
Falls das geht.
So.
Und jetzt sollte ich 100 mal die mittlere Maustaste
angelegt haben. Gucken wir mal.
Bam-bam-bam. Kunst, Leute.
Bam. Guck mal hier.
Klick-klick-klick-klick. Oh fuck. Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht? Erst mal nicht speichern.
Ja.
Klick-klick-klick-klick-klick.
Geht instant.
Mittlere Maustaste.
Aber maximal 100 mal.
Beim 100er Streak hört er auf.
Aber ich glaube 100 mal die mittlere Maustaste
in Folge werde ich eher nicht so oft drücken.
Das ist nicht schön
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es bestimmt besser geht
Wenn man sich mit der Config
Näher auseinandergesetzt hat
Aber bis dahin bleibt das so
So, und jetzt kümmern wir uns mal
Um ein paar andere Sachen
Weil Terminal
Haben wir jetzt erstmal genug
Hübsch gemacht
Mach lieber 1000, ach Quatsch
1000 mal drücke ich doch nicht meine
Wir haben in Firefox eingestellt, dass er der Seite
Mitteilen soll, dass man Dark Mode bevorzugt
Und
Wenn Stack Overflow das nicht
Nicht beachtet, dann
Paints Champ
Sind hier die Klammern, die Klammern sind auf
Meiner Schriftgröße verschoben
Wahnsinn
Ich mein wir können mal
TTF Hack
Uninstallen und
Mit Icons
Drinnen installieren, das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich
E
Oh, was ist jetzt kaputt
Ah Hack
Hack ist Brocken
Okay, nice
Wow, wow, wow
Alter ist ja gut
Please nicht eskalieren Emojis
Font Config Match
Nee, nach was muss ich suchen?
Und Config List ist es
Hack
Wie heißt denn der Krempel jetzt?
Hack, Hack Regular
Nee, Hack Nerd Font brauche ich jetzt
Hack Nerd Font brauche ich jetzt
Jetzt sollte es auch funktionieren, ja jetzt ist gut
Jetzt ist alles wieder zu ernst
Und Klammern immer noch Brocken
Alter, ich hab ernsthaft, seriously
Ich hab es geschafft, die einzige Schriftgröße zu finden
Wo die Klammern nicht richtig aligned sind
Das ist ja Wahnsinn, das kann doch nicht sein
Hier eine Animation
Nee, will ich nicht einbauen
Ich mein, das müsste man jetzt nicht für Bash raussuchen
Okay, Animation in Bash
Ein Spin in Bash
Ein spinnender Progress Balken
Top
Ist das nur in dem Terminal so?
Weiß ich nicht
Gucken wir mal, wie es hier ist
Hier ist es nicht so
Aber das ist ja auch nur in dieser einen Schriftgröße so
Wartet mal, Advanced
Advanced, Default, Colors
Erst einmal
Das da
Oder das bisschen
Oder was auch immer, so
Und jetzt brauchen wir General, Schriftgröße
Heck, Regular
Hier ist es nicht so
Wobei ich hier vielleicht nicht exakt die richtige Schriftgröße treffe
Das kann ja schon sein
Ist aber witzig, das ist exakt
Was hab ich denn hier für eine Schriftgröße?
Ich glaub
Was hab ich denn hier gehabt?
15, 15
Hier ist 12
Da ist es auch so
Mit Schriftgröße 15 ist der Font broken
Geil
Normalerweise verwende ich 16
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab jetzt extra 1 runtergeschaltet
Normalerweise hab ich 16, ich hab seit Jahren schon 16
Aber ich hab 1 runtergeschaltet
Weil ich mir gedacht hab, die Größe ist immer noch gut
Aber es passt ein bisschen mehr drauf
Seriously, es ist einfach broken
Was ein Schwachsinn, Mann
Okay, erstmal den Kram wieder deinstallieren
Ich, ehrlich gesagt
Ich kann damit aber leben
Das bleibt jetzt erstmal so
So, ich würde sagen, mit Terminal sind wir jetzt erstmal durch
Was machen wir denn als nächstes?
Ähm, wir installieren mal ein paar Sachen
Wir installieren Flameshot, Flameshot beste
Flameshot ist eine
Screenshot-Anwendung, die richtig nice ist
Wer das nicht kennt, ich zeige euch das mal
Flameshot, bam
Ja, ist da unten
Jetzt kann man sagen, mach mir mal ein Screenshot
Machen wir mal ein Screenshot
Machen wir mal ein Screenshot hiervon
Und jetzt kann man hier sogar editieren
Kann man drauf rummalen
Oder kann man, was ist das nochmal?
Ein Rectangle kann man machen
Und Pfeile, guck mal so
YouTube Thumbnails
Man kann Blurren, man kann Text drauf machen
Man kann auch irgendwie die Farbe ändern
Das in den Settings dann
Undo, also es ist richtig gut gemacht
Custom Uploader, oh das weiß ich nicht
Ich benutze nie die eingebaute Upload-Funktionalität
von diesen Dingern
Das weiß ich nicht, ob es mehr kann als
Imigur
So, was kann es hier noch
Circle
Marker
Text, Auto-Increment-Counter-Bubble
Okay, was auch immer man damit machen soll
Man kann Sachen Blurren
Das ist sehr praktisch
Kann die Selection Area Moven
Na gut, warte mal, ist meine
Ich dachte meine Katze ist an der Tür
Ja und dann kann man
Speichern natürlich oder Uploaden
Do we want to upload? No
Mal gucken, ob es
Mittlerweile mehr gibt
Mein Auge, so hell
Kann man die Preset-Farben
Kann man die Preset-Farben eingeben
Was sie auf jeden Fall ausschalten ist die Welcome-Message
Hat das ein Dark-Theme mittlerweile?
Boah, da sieht man ja wirklich ganz ganz schlecht was
Ui, ne, okay, was ist das?
Es ist immer noch nur
Imigur
Das geht nicht
Und Flameshot dann auch keine
Hat auch kein Dark-Theme, wobei das überhaupt nicht wild ist
Ehrlich gesagt, ne
Ich mein die Settings, wie oft macht man die auf?
Aber das ist
Wirklich saumäßig nice, das Screenshot-Programm
Hat das Tool
Texterkennung? Ne, ich glaube nicht
Ich weiß nicht, kann es GIFs?
Ich glaube
GIFs kann es auch nicht
Ne, ne, ne, kann es nicht
Das wäre witzig, wenn es auch noch GIF könnte
Aber
Das finde ich nicht schlimm
Im Zweifelsfall Capture ich schnell mit OBS was
GIFs gibt es nicht
Was? VHS?
So wie die Videokassette?
CLI
Home Video Recorder für GIFs
Aha, written in Go
Na dann
Terminal GIFs from Code
Ich will ja nicht zwangsläufig nur Terminal aufnehmen
Ne, das ist was anderes
Also
Flameshot ist nice, aber ich glaube
Flameshot kann nichts anderes als
Imigur
Upload Provider oder so
Custom Domain Uploading
Uploader
Custom Domain Uploader
It's much easier to use a
Wrapper Script for that
Ja
Kann man machen
Man kann einfach Flameshot starten
Und das Bild dann irgendwo hinpipen
Ja das ist
Okay, dann ist es easy
Dann braucht es das auch nicht wirklich eingebaut
Aber ich würde es eh nur für lokale Screenshots benutzen
So
Also
Flameshot ist wirklich eine sehr nice Geschichte
Was brauchen wir dann sonst noch?
Lass mal kurz überlegen
Also das mit Caps Lock, das haben wir schon gemacht
Caps Lock ist Disabled
Firefox, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Braucht noch
Das Dark Theme
Oder Firefox Alpen Glow
Mein Auge
Enable, viel besser
So, jetzt ist Firefox auch
Komplett Dark gethemed
Ich habe einen
1080p Modell, richtig, richtig
1080p 240Hz
So, also das haben wir gemacht
Also das mit Caps Lock haben wir gemacht
So, Icons
Flameshot haben wir auch so
Icons, okay da müssen wir tatsächlich mal gucken
Weil, also auch wegen dieser Leiste da unter
Ich meine die Leiste ist so wirklich
Das ist nix
Das kannst du nicht verwenden
Also aktuell verwende ich das hier
I3 Status Rust
Das ist ehrlich gesagt
Absolut in Ordnung
Das ist fein
Kann man sich auch nicht beschweren
Also das macht was es soll
Aber ich habe was anderes gefunden
Das hier
Das macht auch einen ganz guten Eindruck
Wird beides
Relativ aktiv entwickelt
Relativ, ja
Damit kann man auch verschiedene Status
Dinger generieren
Und das aller wichtigste
Eigentlich
Müssten wir das verwenden, weil das ist written in Rust
Und das hier ist written in
Python oder Go
Äh
In Python
Und nicht Rust
Also da müsste man, eigentlich müsste man das weiter verwenden
Weil Placingly Fast
Kennst du Polybar, ja kenn ich auch
Es gibt hunderte dieser
Dieser Status Ausgaben Dinger
Weiß gar nicht was ich da vernehme
Ganz ehrlich, theoretisch könnten wir dabei bleiben
Weil
Das habe ich schon, da habe ich schon eine Config für
Und eigentlich alles ist, alles gut
Wir schauen jetzt nochmal kurz
Ähm
Was ich nämlich auch ausprobieren wollte
Ist so ein Auto, Autostart
Autostart Ding
Das steht nämlich in der I3 Config
Standardmäßig sogar
Drinnen
Da dachte ich mir, so schlecht kann es nicht sein
Wenn die Default Config das schon
Das schon mit
Mit reinhaut
So, sagen wir Flameshot nochmal
Das es automatisch starten soll
Zack
Und jetzt probieren wir das mal aus
Machen wir jetzt mal
Bam
Ups, Bam
Desktop abschießen
Neu einloggen
Und gucken ob er alles automatisch startet
Ja macht er, macht er
Okay, nice
Übrigens bestes, bestes Hintergrund
Hintergrundbild
Wisst ihr, für alle die gestern nicht dabei waren
Wisst ihr wie wir dieses Bild
Ähm, erstellt haben
Also die ursprüngliche Variante
Ist von Reddit
Allerdings bloß 940 Pixel
940 Pixel
Irgendwie
Ist zu Low Res
Und wir haben das mit AI
Upgescaled
AI Upscaling
Kam jetzt dieses Bild dabei raus
Das ist ein AI Pippo
Sieht man hier an den Konturen ein bisschen
Mein Mikrofon ist verzerrt
War es jetzt schon wieder
Sekunde
Mikrofontest 0w
Hört sich eigentlich ganz normal an
Vielleicht ist es schon mal
Eben gerade
Eben gerade habe ich
Halb über dem Tisch gehangen
Und hatte das halb im Mund stecken
So hier, guck, eben hatte ich das so
Na da hört sich ein bisschen Kacke an, das stimmt
Könnten jetzt auch ASMR Videos machen
Firefox
Ja da weiß ich nicht was wir genau
Was wir da gescheit für verwenden
Also, okay
Ähm, Arch by the way
Ja aber sowas von
By the way, by the way Arch
So wie hat der Typ das jetzt hinbekommen
Dass der ein Icon da drin ist
Ich will eigentlich nicht weiter am Terminal basteln
Das reicht mir jetzt erstmal
Aber guck mal, die haben sogar hier irgendwelche fancy
Fancy Hintergrund
In der Taskbar
Das ist schon nice
Irgendjemand hat doch eben vorhin was geschickt
Wo ich gesagt habe, da muss ich mal gucken
Ähm
Das war irgendwie Tab
Tab Bar
Tab Bar Style
Konki
Ja wenn man drauf steht
Irgendwelche Sachen im Hintergrund anzuzeigen
Ist das ganz nice
Ja brauche ich nicht
Ich gucke eh selten auf dem Desktop
Also insofern
Peacom können wir mal installieren
Es ist kein Multiplexer wie TMAX
Aber du kannst so Sachen hier machen
Die ähnlich sind zu TMAX
Also für Lokal ist das super
Remote über SSH musst du weiter TMAX verwenden
Also eigentlich genauso wie es sein soll
Ansonsten
Ich habe ähnliche Mappings wie auf TMAX
Nur das es kein TMAX ist
Es sieht aber schon
Mit der Leiste hier unten auch
Verdächtig ähnlich
Persistence
Ich weiß nicht ob es sowas wie Sessions hat
Hat es Sessions?
Es hat Workspaces
Irgendwie geht sowas
Workspaces
Kann man irgendwie machen
Switch Workspace Relative
Switch to Workspace
Irgendwas geht hier aber
Muss mich erst mal im Detail beschäftigen
Wenn du jetzt noch TMAX startest
Hast du dann 2 Border
Ja hätte ich auf jeden Fall
Aber ich habe es gar nicht mehr installiert
Weil ich erst mal
Ich werde es auch erst mal nicht mehr benutzen
Lokal
Weil ich die Sache
Guck jetzt hast du 2 Sachen logischerweise
Jetzt kannst du die Leute ganz verwirren
Mit sowas
Remote werde ich es auf jeden Fall weiter verwenden
Remote ist es bei uns auf der Arbeit auch
Eines der Standard Tools schlechthin
Gerade Remote Sessions offen
Wo man dann sagt
Hey können wir mal kurz was zusammen gucken
Ist wirklich ein Eis
Picom
Erst mal wir brauchen ein bisschen Transparenz
Ohne Transparenz geht hier nichts
Picom
Ah yes
Wie ging jetzt Transparenz nochmal
Da muss ich mal
In meine eigene
Config reingucken
Von der alten Kiste
Hiding gleich falls
Ne das war was anderes
Ich glaube die Standard i3 Bar
Konnte keine Transparenz
Das ist es glaube ich
Ja weil jetzt macht der so komische
Überblende Dinger beim Desktop wechseln
Das triggert mich immer
Das dauert mir viel zu lang
Guck mal Leute wenn du ein Desktop wechselst
Und er Faded erst mal so
Da drehst du voll ab bei
Ich meine es sieht zwar schön smooth und weich aus
Aber ich mag es überhaupt nicht
Und dann
Bim
Mkdir config
Picom
Config pic und wie heißt die Datei
Picom conf
Da kommt jetzt das da rein
Fading gleich falls
Und jetzt Fadet da einfach auch nichts mehr
Jetzt schaltet er
Jetzt schaltet er einfach direkt um
Easy und wir haben Transparenz
Aber das
Guck mal
Das Hintergrund durchschreien
Ohne Picom
Ne da hat er das gar nicht
Vielleicht soll ich Picom einfach komplett raus lassen
Ich hatte früher Picom weil
Ich kann es euch sagen
Weil die Performance im Browser teilweise
Bisschen
Bisschen mies war
Also gerade beim scrollen
Wenn sich viel im Browser bewegt hat
Da hat es geruckelt
Da war es nicht so smooth wie es sein könnte
Und das ist mit Picom
Bisschen gefühlt ein bisschen besser
Wenn man hier scrollt
Mit dem neuen Rechner
Ist es kaum noch zu spüren
Also vielleicht
Vielleicht lasse ich das einfach auch ganz weg
Ich meine wozu
Ne ne ich brauche es für die Transparenz
Ich brauche es für die Transparenz von der Leiste
Ohne sonst gibt es nicht
Ohne
Ich brauche Transparenz
Sonst das nervt mich wenn das hier unten
Also ich zeige es euch mal bei meiner alten Vm
Bei meiner alten Vm sieht das so aus
Seht ihr da habe ich hier eine Transparenz in der Leiste
So muss das sein
Der Slider rechts ist viel zu schmal
Welcher Slider rechts
Das da bei Firefox
Ja das verwende ich normalerweise auch nie
Ich mache immer Mausrad scrolling
Oder hier Bild hoch, Bild runter
Post 1 und Ende
Wir richten weiter die
Linux Vm ein
So wir gucken jetzt mal das wir unten ordentliche Statusleiste
Hinkriegen weil so ist das ziemlich
Ziemlich
Hippiger
Ich brauche tatsächlich einen File Manager
Normalerweise benutze ich eigentlich
Nahezu alles
Aber ab und zu
Ab und zu brauchen wir noch einen File Manager
Hauptsächlich zum Beispiel
Für, weil das am besten damit geht
Von Windows rein
Track und Drop Copy Pasten
Guck wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
Das hier von Windows reinpasten will
Also reinpasten geht noch
Reinpasten geht noch weil wenn man das in die Shell macht
Ich kann euch das mal zeigen
Wenn man das in die Shell macht dann kriege ich den Fad
Hier rein kopiert
Ach ne das geht gar nicht mehr
Interessant
Früher konnte man das auf die Shell kopieren
Dann hatte man hier den Fad gehabt
Guck mal da oben was da oben jetzt in der Ecke hängt
Allein schon deswegen braucht man
Irgendeinen GUI File Manager
Wenn man von seinem Host ab und zu mal
Was Track und Dropen will
Guck mal ich habs kaputt gemacht jetzt hängt da oben das Ding
Wir haben Vmware
Gebrickt
Mal gucken ob es funktioniert wenn ich
Das Manjaro, nein Arch by the way
Das ist ein original Arch
Stören dich die 60 Hertz?
Ist das jetzt von Vmware eigentlich?
Nö
Oh jetzt habe ich irgendwas kaputt gemacht
Ich habs gebrickt
Zum komischen Copy Paste Versuch
Komplett
From scratch genau
Restore Session
Vm kaputt
Also zum Copy Paste
Brauche ich diesen
File Manager zum Beispiel wenn ich das hier
Wenn ich Stream kopieren will
In meinen Explorer
Das geht nur gescheit mit dem GUI
File Manager und deswegen
Müssten wir das grad nochmal
Bisschen verschönern
Die Icons muss ich sagen sind mittlerweile
Wirklich in Ordnung
Vim File Manager
Ja das funktioniert mit Track und Drop nicht richtig
Wie gesagt es muss irgendeine GUI Anwendung sein
Das Vmware das checkt
Normalerweise habe ich gar keinen also wenn ich das nicht in der Vmware installiere
Habe ich gar keinen GUI File Manager
Achtung
Blendgranate
Und Maus
Ist eigentlich absolut in Ordnung
Icon Theme ist auch ok
Ich brauche mir hier gar nichts anpassen
Doch wir passen an
Show Images und Buttons
Cantuna Tabs
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Wie gesagt ich verwende das nur zum Track und Drop aus und in die Vm
Ansonsten eigentlich gar nichts
Ne ich glaube nicht das es Tabs kann
Splitt View
Ok anscheinend
Kannst du irgendwie mehrere Sachen aufmachen
Can Tabs
Echt wie Ctrl T
Ah ja tatsächlich Can Tabs
Interessant
War mir so nicht bewusst
War mir so gar nicht bewusst
Ich verwende das normalerweise auch gar nicht
Nur für Track und Drop aus und in die Vm
So das ist schonmal ganz nice
Ok
Wie entlocken wir dem Ding da unten denn jetzt
Mal Transparenz
Du hast GitHub Polybar
Also ich habe Polybar noch nie verwendet
Es ist
Es gibt so viele Sachen
Es gibt Polypire
Es gibt I3 Status RS
Es gibt Bumblebee
Es gibt I3 Status Self
Es gibt total viel Zeug
Bisher habe ich mich noch nicht mit Polybar auseinander gesetzt
Was wie heißt das Ding EWW
Was ist das für ein Ding
Es gibt da so viel Zeug von
Elko was
Elko was Wacky Widgets
Alles klar
Es gibt so viel Zeug
Oh Made in Rust
Leute
Dann ist ja eigentlich schonmal klar was wir nehmen müssen oder
Wir haben die Auswahl zwischen
Nicht written in Rust und written in Rust
Besteht da auch was von Blazingly Fast drinnen
Davon habe ich beispielsweise noch nie was gehört
Wacky Widgets
Widget System Made in Rust
Which lets you create your own Widgets
Na das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben jetzt
Kannst du quasi komplett mit GTK
oder so eigene
eigene Confed....
Bars zusammenzimmern
Das ist dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen
Overkill
Punkt Jack
HÜ meaningless
Ist das irgendwie Lisp
Nein nein
Mit
Irgendnem komischem Lisp Dialekt
fangen wir jetzt nicht an
Auf gar keinen Fall
das hässlichste was es gibt gibt es gibt es paar gescheite examples von polybar so was kann man
dann hier machen doch ich meine ich könnte auch einfach das nehmen was ich bisher genommen habe
weil ich bin damit voll voll voll und ganz zufrieden ehrlich gesagt das sieht dann so
aus ungefähr ampels screenshots gibt kein image ampelbar sieht dann so aus ist das was ich bisher
meine alten vm hatte u launcher anstatt profi warum das denn also ruf ich finde ich ist das
beste jula und schafft was ist der vorteil deiner meinung nach von jula und ich finde
rufi ist eine super geschichte kannst du clipboard integrieren kannst du im modus
election
reinmachen alles mögliche bin ich finde ich super super geschichte das dem ist übrigens
auch noch ist der abend grad fällt mir geradezu ein ad menu haben wir aktuell gerade aber es
dürfte ein bisschen ein bisschen schicker dürfte schon sein mein rufi setup hier das
was ich die ganze zeit ja verwendet die window icons sind für mich das killer feature welche
window icons du meinst dass da auch dass du die fenster durchsuchen kannst
also ich hab ich habe einmal rowe film führmer clipboard manager und zum starten von programm
das ist eigentlich die zwei sachen die ich verwende laufd stark gestalten copy-paste
einfügen naja ist das habe ich bei mir habe ich bei mir in der in der terministik urla storyteller
das ding überhaupt aus launcher ist das ist das ades anwendung irgendwie
urla verwendet-bt-player markt ist bestehende urla und testen-smart tragedy modろ ich bin ohne urla so Done und da got i got amptek red eyan tor schreuer auf fm wie sieht es denn ein für bei outta textot intéressiert mich auch bio schon wenn ihr nehmt euch gerne einen væ Meteor
Irgendwie schreit es ein bisschen Node.js.
Python-Anwendung?
Kannst du die Register mit dem Clipboard-Manager
dann auch mit WIM verbinden?
Ich klicke im Clipboard-Manager das an
und dann wird es ins System-Clipboard kopiert
und dann kann ich es auch in WIM einfügen.
Es unterstützt nicht
die 95 verschiedenen
WIM-Clipboards.
Was ist denn das?
Python, okay.
Profi ist glaube ich C++
MonkaS.
Scroll noch ein Stück runter.
Äh, wo hier?
GitHub. Und?
Achso, du meinst die Bilder, wie die aussehen.
Ach, das hier meinst du.
Ja, das.
Wahrscheinlich ist da ein bisschen auch noch
Ist da vielleicht doch ein Embedded-Browser
dahinter irgendwie?
Könnte das sein?
Also ich bin mit Profi wirklich sehr zufrieden.
Ich wüsste nicht
warum ich das switchen sollte.
Und wird beides super aktiv
entdeckt.
Ist das für alle, die es benutzen?
Also was spricht
da jetzt dagegen?
Fuzzy Search?
Ich meine, wir können es einfach mal installieren.
Ich meine,
wir sind ja hier, um neue Sachen auszuprobieren.
Okay.
Es gibt schon mal kein offizielles
Package.
Nur User-Repos.
Das ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlimm,
aber es ist doof.
Ja, wir nehmen den.
Wo ist er denn?
Rofi Emoji?
Das brauchen wir unbedingt.
Okay, es gibt es gibt
Rofi Moji und Rofi Emoji.
Was ist denn jetzt?
Was ist denn davon besser?
Wir installieren das Ding erst mal.
29.
Paro wurde mir gestern schon vorgeschlagen.
Hab ich den Sinn nicht drin gesehen.
Rofi Moji haben wir zur Auswahl.
Was? Rofi Emoji?
Ich mache übrigens noch keinen Emoji Picker.
Also vielleicht ist das ja mal was Neues.
Rofi Emoji. Gibt es beides.
Also wir haben
die Auswahl zwischen
irgendwas, was aktiv entwickelt wird
und was nicht. Also nehmen wir
Rofi Emoji.
Im Prinzip machen sie beide
mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Emoji Selector.
Character Picker.
Main Features. Na gut.
Dann probieren wir das mal aus. Rofi Emoji.
Emoji. Alles klar.
Gib ihm. Was zum Teufel ist Fussel?
Und Wofi?
What the f... Ich blick nochmal durch.
So. Also jetzt haben wir das.
Nerdfond. Brauchen wir nicht.
Optional Dependencies. Wozu?
Ach Wayland.
Wayland Zeug.
Ne brauchen wir nicht.
Ich hab eigentlich den Nerdfond installiert.
Ich hab den
Nerdfond Hack
hab ich installiert.
Hier. ETF.
Also ich weiß nicht warum er der Meinung ist,
dass ich das nicht habe. Aber gut.
Okay.
Und jetzt Rofi. Bam.
Da ist er. Ach ja.
Das hat jetzt sogar
einen Assistent
so irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das ist jetzt auch neu.
The following modes are available.
Also Rofi Emoji.
So.
Wo ist das Problem?
Could not find a valid way to type characters.
Doch. Meine Tastatur ist wunderbar
um Characters zu typen.
Please check required dependencies.
Okay.
Dependencies.
Python. Ja. A font that can display your
Display your
Scripts.
Was? Ach so.
Ach zum Einfügen. Okay.
XdoTool
Brauchen wir. Ja ja. Verstehe.
Okay. Leuchtet ein.
Rofi Emoji. Ah da sind wir.
Kekkel. Gibt es nicht.
Wie hieß
dieses Emoji, wo alle ein Problem
mit haben. Hier.
Das da.
Lächelndes Gesicht mit Lachen.
Lächelndes Gesicht.
EN. Please.
Ne.
Englisch.
Meine Browsersprache muss ich noch umstellen.
Ganz wichtig.
Language.
Ne habe ich doch.
Choose your preferred language.
Englisch.
Warum komme ich dann hier auf Deutsch raus?
Google.
Google angeboten auf Englisch.
Jo. Viel besser.
Und jetzt komme ich auch auf der englischen Seite raus.
Okay. Also Smiling muss ich
suchen. Smiling. Smiling
Face with
So. Was ist das?
Smiling. Einfach nur Smiling
Face. Das ist das, wo das Ding
so rumbarkt. Smiling
Face with Smiling Eyes.
Das normale
ist da schon gar nicht mehr drinnen.
So. Das ist natürlich auch praktisch.
Ach guckt mal. Der merkt sich.
Der merkt sich tatsächlich auch, was man zuletzt
eingefügt hat. Guck mal.
Wenn ich das jetzt nochmal aufmache.
Jetzt weiß er. Ich habe
das hier so die Top 10
Emojis, die ich irgendwie verändert habe.
Und wie kann ich die jetzt auswählen?
Wie kann ich die jetzt selecten?
Wenn ich das nochmal einfügen will.
Thinking
haben wir noch. Ja. Cool.
So. Und wie
bekomme ich die jetzt
dahinten?
Eins, zwei, drei. Wie funktioniert das?
By default uses bla bla bla
so. Hinten.
Maus.
Ne.
Most recently. Most alt und eins.
Aha. Mit alt. Also sprich
zwei. Dann kommt die Katze.
Sehr praktisch. Finde ich
finde ich nice.
Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen. Gefällt
mir besser als das Windows Ding.
So. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal
den Theme Selector.
Was hatte ich nochmal
für einen Theme? Das nicht. Das nicht.
Das nicht. Das nicht. Das nicht. Das nicht.
Das nicht.
Das nicht. Das auch nicht.
Gleich kommt hier diese komische
Schildkröte Leute. Wo ich mich jedes mal frage.
Warum ist das überhaupt dabei?
Ja. Kann ich dir gleich zeigen.
Das geht ganz gut. Das ist nix.
Das ist nix.
Nix. Nix.
Das geht noch halbwegs.
Da ist die Schildkröte
wieder. Das ist
glaube ich einfach nur irgendwie aus Spaß da
drin aus. So just for fun.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh Iggy
Monokai
Paper Purple
Sidebar
Jetzt haben wir es gebrocken.
Ähm.
Okay. Mein Theme ist da gar nicht dabei.
Wo habe ich denn das her?
Was verwende ich denn da?
Moment. Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz abgucken.
Was habe ich denn da?
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Was ich hier am Start habe. Bei dem alten
Ähm.
Was ist das für ein Theme?
Warte mal. Less config
Ruf
Config
Äh.
Das da? Slate.
Gut. Das war die alte
Die alte VM.
Ruf wie Slate.
This repository has been archived.
Warum wurde das
archived? Ha.
Das ist aber doof.
Ja da müssen wir uns eines der offiziellen
Themes aussuchen.
Okay.
Was taucht noch am ehesten?
Android notification
Äh.
Das sieht doch alles
Dark blue demon
Okay.
Die Schildkröte werde ich nicht nehmen.
Die gefallen mir alle nicht.
Das geht ja noch am ehesten klar.
Das gefällt mir alles nicht.
Das sieht alles doof aus.
Was soll denn das sein?
Da erkennst du ja gar nichts.
Das ist alles
Gibt es da irgendwie neues
Themes collection
Gibt es da vielleicht im Repo welche?
Okay. Da gibt es
User Repos. Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Rufi
Ich meine die machen ja
schon mal ganz gute Sachen. Das ist ja eine eigene
Eine eigene Distribution
Okay. Was bin ich sehend?
Chat. Was ihr mir hier gepostet habt.
Launchers. A huge collection
of Rufi based custom applets
Launchers und Powermenus
Okay.
Setup. Edit
Launchers. Was?
Da ist wieder 30 Milliarden Sachen
dabei. Ja das sieht schon mal
deutlich schicker aus als das
andere. Style 1
Ja das finde ich
sehr nett sowas.
Colorscreen. Adapter Arc Black
Cat Pucine
One Dark
Das sieht schick aus glaube ich. Ja.
Das sind so Sachen das ist in Ordnung.
Ja das finde ich ganz ganz schick. Loveless
Das kann man sich
alles geben.
Ja.
Kann man installieren. Also wie funktioniert das? Launchers
Oh das ist schick.
Das gefällt mir. Das ist aber kein Rufi
oder? Oder doch?
Was passiert da gerade? Was passiert
hier?
Was sehe ich da
überhaupt? Okay.
Das verwirrt mich was das überhaupt ist.
Wie sieht das bei denen aus?
Okay wie funktioniert das ganze?
Rufi
Themes
Rufi Theme Launcher
Das ist das hier.
Large Collection oder? Da gibt es
eine User Repo von
Large
Das ist das hier oder? Was es da über
das User Repo gibt.
Würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Huge Collection das ist das hier.
Powermenu Launcher.
Ich checke allerdings ehrlich gesagt nicht was da
im Unterschied ist.
Rufi Theme Used. Rufi Theme Powermenu.
Rufi Theme Launcher.
Applets?
Da bin ich zu low IQ für.
Was jetzt was ist?
Applets? Battery?
Da musst du studieren. Das ist richtig richtig
high IQ Zeug.
Ich installiere das jetzt mal.
Launcher Applets.
Powermenus?
Hat Powermenu was zu tun mit
Batterie oder so?
Achso ne das ist
quasi so eine Art Plugin dafür.
Ok also installieren wir mal.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Rufi Theme Menu
Launcher. Was mich schon wieder
verwirrt ist das es hier tausend
verschiedene Packages
von gibt. Und wie
kommen die auf irgendwelche Versionen? Der Typ hat
auch nie eine Version released bisher.
Egal schauen wir mal. Was haben wir denn hier?
First Member Clone
Changed Clone Directory Setup
Setup ausführen.
Ich bin da eigentlich immer so ein bisschen
Wie kommen die
Jungs hier auf die Versionsnummer?
Version?
Was macht denn das Setup?
Install Fonts?
Alter das installiert mir wieder 30 Milliarden
Sachen auf meinem System.
Ja anscheinend gibt es keine User.
Da musst du wirklich studieren für.
Wisst ihr was wir installieren das jetzt einfach mal easy.
Wir haben noch ne
VM.
Schade doch nix.
Lone.
Ich muss sagen ich mach so Sachen eigentlich
ungern. Ich benutze mittlerweile
ehrlich gesagt am liebsten
halbwegs offizielle Packages
ohne so viel dazu zu machen.
Weil das breakt halt ab und zu mal
und du weißt dann immer nicht genau
woran es jetzt liegt.
Ok. Setup.
Auf geht's.
Installed successfully. Ok.
Fonts. Ok.
Irgendwas. Also.
Dann.
Profi.
Theme Selector. Habe ich jetzt mehr zur Auswahl?
Auch nicht wirklich oder?
Und.
Was mache ich jetzt?
That's it.
Themes are now installed on your system.
Ok.
Ja. Ja.
Ok. Und jetzt?
Ist da irgendwas neues
jetzt dabei gekommen?
Ne oder? Neustarten?
Edit. Hier.
Edit.
Config. Rofi. Launchers.
Script.
Datei gibt's nicht. Alter.
Was zum Teufel ist das denn?
Wie soll man denn da durchblicken man?
Config. Rofi. Colors.
Ok. Da ist der Krempel schon mal.
Aber One Dark steht ja auch nicht drinne.
Vielleicht muss ich erstmal
initial ein Theme auswählen,
das sich die Config Datei anlegt. Ok.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach das Default Theme
und sag.
Wie saved man das?
Accept Steuerung A.
Ok.
Config.
Rofi. Launchers.
Type.
Ach jetzt muss ich auswählen welchen
Launcher Type ich haben will.
Also nehmen wir mal Type.
Keine Ahnung. Type 2.
Type 3.
Ok. Type 3.
Und jetzt?
Die Config ist weird. Weird.
Edit the script
and edit the following line to use
the style you like.
Style minus 1.
Moment. Launcher?
Ach Type 3 gibt es da nochmal verschiedene Themes.
Oder wie?
Richtig high IQ Shit. Alter.
Bis man da dahinter gekommen ist.
Ok. Ich lass jetzt mal Default.
Kann man das jetzt einfach ausführen?
Ah hier. Das ist ganz schick.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Leute. Das ist ein ganz relativ
hübscher Launcher.
Ein hübscher Launcher.
Und wie changed man jetzt die Color?
Was macht denn der Typ noch? Hat er noch mehr so Design
Stelzkram?
Rofi. Archcraft.
Was ist Archcraft?
Polybar Themes. Ach der Typ
ist das.
Dynamic Wallpaper. Ok.
Interessant. Was hat denn der noch alles?
Ein Thermux.
Ach das ist dieses
Android Terminal Ding.
Sort by?
Kann man die Repos? Konnte man die Repos nicht irgendwie
nach Sternen sortieren?
Ach hier doch Stars.
Der Typ hat ja sau viel
gut designte Sachen
anscheinend. Hier hast du beispielsweise
Boot Logos
und sowas.
Ja warum nicht?
Was sind denn Slim Themes?
Ach ein Login Manager. Ok.
Archcraft.
Dynamic Wallpaper.
A bash script to set
Wallpapers.
Hä? Das ist ne
coole Idee.
Ich mein ich guck meinen Hintergrund
nie an. Ja und es bleibt bei mir
der Pepo Happy im Hintergrund.
Aber die Idee ist
cool. Die gefällt mir.
Der hat bestimmt auch so ne Designer
Kaffeemaschine für
8-9.000 Euro. Ja bestimmt.
Das ist aber die Idee
ist cool.
Man bräuchte Pepo Happy
quasi in verschiedenen
in verschiedenen Ausgaben.
Beispielsweise jetzt müsste das
müsste das quasi
ihn so in Bettgepose anzeigen.
Das wär cool oder?
Pepo Happy Daily.
Morgens so verschlafen
danach essen,
Zähne putzen, dann irgendwann Mittagessen
und irgendwann abends Bett getimed.
Müssten wir mal irgendeinen Fiverr
Fiverr Designer beauftragen.
Sowas zu erstellen.
Die Dynamic
Pepo Wallpaper.
I may be slow
to respond.
Responde so schnell du willst.
Oh das sieht auch schick aus.
Das finde ich ganz nett hier
von dem Typ.
Und das ist nicht so Overkill.
Das sind einfach ein paar Themes.
Also wenn das mal nicht
Mac iOS
MacOS geklaut ist, dann weiß ich
auch nicht. Okay es heißt auch schon Spotlight.
Das ist schon äußerst
stark inspiriert.
Aber das finde ich
finde ich gar nicht.
Ganz bestimmt nicht unter Linux.
Ich glaube das ist mir fast
lieber so ein
einfach nur ein paar Themes
installiert.
Alter was mit dem tut hier los?
Das besteht ja aus 30 Milliarden
verschiedene Sachen.
So okay zumindest so kann man
das starten.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz nett.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz cool.
So und da gibt es jetzt was noch verschiedene Typen
davon.
Launcher Typ 1, 2, 3
Also wir können hier beispielsweise Launcher Typ
1 machen. Das sieht dann so aus.
Oder Launcher Typ 2.
Das sieht dann so aus. Okay ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht.
Dann haben wir noch Launcher Typ 3.
Sieht so aus.
Launcher Typ 4.
Launcher Typ 5.
MonkaS.
Iles durchsuchen.
Tackle.
Aber wenn man es
braucht.
Window durchsuchen.
Run.
Hier hat er keine Icons richtig.
Ah ne bei Apps sind wir richtig.
So dann haben wir 7, 8
äh.
7 hört auf.
Btop++ Failed to launch
Terminal. Excellent.
Naja gut.
So und das gibt es jetzt noch.
Type 3.
Gibt es jetzt noch in unterschiedlichen.
Also der Typ übertreibt es hier wirklich.
Mit
Complicated machen.
Weil die Dinger gibt es jetzt auch noch in Styles.
Die gibt es jetzt auch noch in verschiedenen Styles.
Also sprich Typ 3.
Wir haben Typ 3.
Und den gibt es jetzt irgendwie nochmal in
Tja ich weiß ja nicht wie viele Styles.
Typ 3
hat 10 verschiedene Styles.
Also fangen wir mal an.
1. Wir machen das mal so.
Da können wir besser editieren.
Mist.
Ich brauche unbedingt. Ich muss unbedingt ZSH
installieren. Ich brauche gesharete.
Ich brauche gesharete
History und sowas. Das ist sonst.
Hallo?
Genau.
Mist.
Okay. Ups. Mann.
Was mache ich denn da?
Aha. Jetzt ist es ein bisschen transparent.
Auch gar nicht mal so übel.
So.
Style 2.
Okay.
Komplett transparent. Das ist nichts.
Style 3.
Kenne ich keinen Unterschied.
Erkennt ihr einen Unterschied?
Style 4.
Gefällt bis jetzt gefällt mir der am besten.
Wobei.
Was ist denn das?
Wobei ich das ja ehrlich gesagt horizontal
mehr mag.
Dann haben wir
Style 5.
Okay.
Den finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Da gefällt mir die Schriftart nicht.
Style 6.
Der installiert mir aber auch ein bisschen zu viel Zeug.
Okay. Bitte noch fetter alles.
Style 7.
Okay. Das ist ganz in Ordnung.
Style 8.
Nee. Das ist links.
Hängen ist doof.
Okay. Jetzt hängt der Kram rechts.
Und als letztes
wieder 10.
Oh.
Ich weiß nicht.
Da hängt auch so viel Zeug dran.
Ich probiere das mal hier mit aus.
Moment.
Wir machen das von dem anderen Dude nochmal.
Ich meine der hat Launcher-Config am Start.
Applets.
Für irgendwie allen möglichen
Krempel.
Für Volume anpassen.
Screenshot machen.
Was ist MIME schon wieder?
Weil es gibt so viele Programme unter Linux.
MIME.
Take Screenshots from your Desktop.
Ja gut. Da habe ich.
Da habe ich jetzt ja
Fireshot für.
Kann das GIFs? Nö.
Okay. Dann kannst du
Bookmarks, Screenshot, Brightness,
Battery Apps.
Immerhin.
Eins muss ich dir mal zugute halten.
Der hat überall.
Der hat überall schöne Bilder.
Das du dir das im Vorfeld angucken kannst.
Nimm K-Snip.
Ey.
Ganz ehrlich. Flameshot ist mega nice.
Ah. Da kannst du sogar jetzt
noch rum machen. Das ist ja ein halbes Paint, Mann.
Kann das GIFs?
Wenn es GIFs kann, würde
ich es gleich nehmen. Dann brauche ich kein OBS
für GIFs. Nein.
Deswegen habe ich immer noch
Share X unter Windows.
Das kann das.
Okay. Sirius Max sagt
Was hast du?
Launcher Typ 2.
Style 2.
Style 2. Okay.
Ja. Der geht tatsächlich ganz gut
klar.
Aber ich mache mal kurz das andere
hier hin. Ganz ehrlich.
Das erscheint mir
Rofi Theme Collection.
Einfach Git Clone und gutes
Installing Themes.
CD Repos.
Zack. Git Clone.
Ja. Gut. Das habe ich.
Copy your desired theme.
Ja. Machen wir.
Ah. Peak. Peak hat übelst viel
Memory Usage. Ach. Gibt es das
gar nicht?
Was? Local?
Config?
Rofi?
Moment. Die Themes kommen wieder woanders
hin oder was?
Können sich wieder nicht entscheiden
oder was? Oder wie? Oder wo?
Was ist das hier?
Warum braucht man dafür schon wieder einen extra Ordner?
Keck Wait.
CP Themes. Also
CD. Rofi
Theme Collection.
Okay. Zack. Copy.
Wir kopieren da einfach alle
hin.
Bam.
So.
CD.
Da haben wir es. So. Und jetzt können wir die
können wir hoffentlich im Theme Collector
auswählen
jetzt. Ja.
Okay. Okay. Sieht schon besser aus. Also.
Ähm. Das sind glaube ich
alle die mitgeliefert werden.
Bis hier hin.
Und jetzt. So. Launchpad.
Okay. Schau mal. Broken.
Schau mal. Broken funktionieren
die Icons nicht.
Nord One Line.
Nord. Nord Two Line.
Nord Rounded.
Rounded Common.
Ist Broken. Nice.
Sehr gut. GG Eats.
Funktioniert ja wunderbar.
Ganz toll.
Das sieht aber auf der Webseite
von dem Dude deutlich, deutlich nicer aus.
Okay. Probieren wir es mal aus.
Accept.
Okay. Und jetzt starten wir das mal. Rofi.
Ähm. Oh. Wie ist
der App Launcher dafür?
D Run?
Nee. Run?
Nee.
Das war ja aus dem Kopf. Wie startet man den
D Run?
Nee.
Show. Minus Show.
Ah ja. Das da.
Das war eigentlich ganz okay.
Kann man tatsächlich.
Kann man tatsächlich ganz gut mit leben.
Ja.
Lass uns mal kurz auf der Webseite von dem Typ
gucken was da. Also Windows 11
werde ich garantiert.
Pass mal auf. Pass mal auf.
Windows 11
List Dark.
Ja. Wunderbar.
Naja gut.
An Windows. An Windows 11
erinnert mich das jetzt nicht wirklich.
Es ist in der Mitte. Okay.
Das war es aber.
Squared North. Das ist auch ganz
gut. Ich muss euch sagen das alte was ich die ganze
Zeit hatte gefällt mir immer noch am besten.
Spotlight Dark war glaube ich auch ganz
gut. Simple Tokyo
Night. Was ist das?
Rounded. Rounded war
broken. Rounded war broken.
Launchpad.
Launchpad probieren wir mal aus.
Und Tokyo.
Ne Moment.
Das hängt dann irgendwie an der Seite.
Das ist schon mal Mist.
Geh weg.
Ne nicht. Ne Rounded.
Ne wie hieß das andere jetzt mal.
Ich hab Gedächtnis gerade.
Launchpad war das genau.
Launchpad.
Okay.
Ist auch okay.
Ich weiß nicht ganz ehrlich.
Mein aktuelles Theme gefällt mir nicht.
Eigentlich am besten.
Das ist wirklich halber Gnaum.
Bzzzt.
Der scheiß Gnaum. Bzzzt.
Gnaum hat das ja auch.
Ach ich weiß nicht.
Überzeugt mich jetzt alles
nicht so sehr wenn ich
ehrlich bin.
Ich lass mal so ein Standard Ding.
Das hat mich an
Komplexität
Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt an Komplexität
ein bisschen überfordert.
Das ist ja einfach mal
das Beste von dem Dude hier.
Typ 2 Launcher.
Und das gibt es ja dann auch noch in
was wie viele?
Ganz ehrlich das ist wahrscheinlich
so das hier noch am angenehmsten.
Da gibt es auch noch Unterschiede.
Was es gibt auch noch Unterschiede.
Die Color Themes?
Moment.
Wo? Color?
Ach du scheiße.
Hahaha.
Ne.
Das habe ich doch schon alles durchprobiert hier.
Die Themes.
Style 1, 2, 3.
Moment. Ne. Ne. Moment.
Directory.
Dann ist die Frage was man hier.
Ok. One Dark.
One Dark.
Change Colors. Edit.
Ok. Das ist.
Der bräuchte irgendein Setup Script dafür.
Das ist doch abartig.
Da blickt doch
keiner mehr durch.
Und wo gibt es jetzt hier
einen Vorschau wenigstens für verschiedene Color Themes?
Oder One Dark?
Ne. Das muss man dann
alle Steps ausprobieren.
Oder hat er Bilder? Previews?
Ne.
Scheiße man.
Du kannst
einfach Color Themes
aufklappen. Wo denn?
Ach hier.
Ah. Ok.
One Dark.
One Dark ist anscheinend
Default.
Not Loveless
Cut Puzine.
Der Kerl mag Blautöne.
Nicht so mein Fall.
Waren das jetzt unterschiedliche
Bilder? Sah alles so ähnlich aus.
Ok. Sieht tatsächlich.
Ne. Ne. Leute. Ist tatsächlich unterschiedlich.
Sieht tatsächlich unterschiedlich aus.
Aber nur.
Aber nur minimal.
Ne. Also das ist mir. Das ist mir für einen Launcher
doch ein bisschen zu
abgedreht komplex.
Ich meine das hier geht.
Das geht durchaus klar.
Wobei mir halt die Schriftart nicht wirklich gut gefällt.
Ok. Also was soll ich
nehmen? Das da.
Das ist Color 4.
Und das ändert mir jetzt
Wie
heißt das Ding?
Ok.
Ok. Sieht das jetzt anders aus als vorher?
Sah das jetzt anders aus?
Ok. Ich mach mal einen Schreibfehler.
Und dann lädt das immer noch.
Das hat sich jetzt nichts geändert.
Gerade. Ok. Wir machen mal was
was definitiv anders aussieht.
Ähm.
You.
User. Das war irgendwie
gelb oder sowas.
Ne. Da ändert sich an der Optik ja gar nichts.
Da gibt es keine Dienste
zum Durchstarten. Wir sind nicht unter Windows.
Jetzt blinke ich. Jetzt hört's
bei mir auf. Jetzt blinke ich nicht mehr durch.
Jetzt blinke ich nicht mehr durch.
Ach. Colors in Type 5,
6 und 7 mal Hardcoded.
Aber ich hab
Style 2 und Typ 2.
Da ist es nicht Hardcoded.
Moment. Change Color.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig
editiert? Moment.
Moment. Wo habe ich denn hier
überhaupt was?
Wo habe ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt
editiert? Ich habe
in irgendeinem anderen.
Moment. Ich habe im falschen Ordner editiert.
Haha. Mein Gott.
Alter. Wie kompliziert ist das?
Ist
Type 2.
So. Und da will ich jetzt
das da haben.
Lull. Alter.
Type 2.
So. Und wie sieht das jetzt aus?
Es sieht jetzt anders aus.
Okay. Wunderbar.
MonkaS.
Das ist ja abartig
kompliziert.
Workstation ist
nicht gratis. Ne.
Ähm. Der neue Play
ist auch nicht mehr gratis. Da muss man ein bisschen
also. Der Player ist schon noch
gratis. Allerdings gibt es jetzt so eine
kostenpflichtige Player Variante.
Und VMware hat dafür gesorgt,
dass man das nicht mehr
ordentlich findet.
Die kostenlose Variante.
Ne. Das ist alles was da drin steht.
Wie kann man denn. Font.
Wie passt man an RoFi den Font
nochmal an?
RoFi Font.
Font
Configuration.
Wo?
Ah. Minus Font.
Show.
Minus Font.
Keckel.
Das gibt es nicht.
Ah. Ne. Okay.
Wie habe ich denn den Font.
Wie habe ich denn den Font hier
konfiguriert?
Habe ich das in meiner i3 Config drin mit dem
Font?
Schauen wir mal.
Hier. Minus. Hä? Gibt es doch.
Minus Font. Hack.
Ah. Hier. Show Icons.
Ach. Show D Run.
Braucht man. Okay.
RoFi Show D Run.
Okay.
Copy Pasten wir das mal.
Okay. So. Und das können wir jetzt
da drinnen mal editieren.
Hier mal hin.
Show D Run.
Show Icons.
Font Hack Display.
Ein bisschen customizen das Ganze.
Aber der Font.
Ändert sich nicht.
Warum ändert sich der Font nicht?
Vielleicht muss ich den Font.
Vielleicht muss ich den als erstes angeben.
Der ist bestimmt im Theme irgendwie definiert.
Und man kann. Ne. Das ist mir.
Die Config ist mir zu. Zu.
Zu wir. Von diesem.
Von diesem Ding.
Der nutzt irgendwelche Hardcoded.
Irgendwelche Hardcoded Fonts.
Ach. Da gibt es. Da gibt es
eine Datei für.
Also sprich.
Type. Also müssen wir.
Launchers.
Type Fonts. Ne.
Shared.
Fonts.
Fonts. Okay.
Hack 16.
Ah.
Ah. Okay.
Finde ich jetzt schon ein bisschen. Aber irgendwie gefällt es mir nicht.
Ganz ehrlich. Ich glaube ich
kopiere mir mein Theme von dem alten rüber.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich finde das hier wirklich sehr nice.
So richtig.
Ohne. Da. Da.
Das sieht halt einfach.
Nach einer Liste aus.
Fertig.
Nimm das mit Spotlight. Okay.
Ich meine das alte ist halt sehr
minimalistisch. Ja.
Es ist halt schlicht ergreifend eine Liste untereinander.
Und das war es.
Das ist auch. Finde ich vollkommen.
Vollkommen ausreichend. Das. Das andere
ist total. Over. Over
Engineert.
Meinst. Du meinst das mit.
Spotlight Dark.
Das da. Ist eigentlich auch
ganz okay. Oder.
Beachtet das überhaupt mein Font?
Ne. Das beachtet auch nicht mein Font.
Und auch nicht mein Run Icon.
Das springt beim Suchen
zu viel. Ja. Wie verhält sich
da mein Altes?
Moment. Hier. Mal. Mal.
Starten. Ja.
Das ist. Mein Altes ist viel besser.
Guck mal.
Das bleibt einfach immer offen.
Auf der Kleidung. Das ist besser.
Ja. Ne. Ne. Ne. Das fliegt.
Alles weg. Gut. Leute.
Gut. Das ich einen.
Ne. Nicht da.
Gut. Das ich ein Snapshot gemacht habe.
Auf Snapshot 3.
Das nimmt nämlich dieser ganze
Shit wieder weg. Das ist mir
alles zu übertrieben und zu kompliziert.
Ich mein. Seriously.
Was ist das? 500 Bash
Scripts und 30
Dinger um
seinen Launcher ein bisschen
schick zu machen. Wir machen jetzt mal
Just for Fun.
Moment. Äh.
Rofi Theme.
Das da machen wir nochmal.
Wow. What the hell.
Installiert erstmal nen Gnome hinterher.
Lip X Klavier.
Nope.
Achso. Ne. Ne. Ne. Abbrechen.
Abbrechen. Abbrechen. Wie hieß das andere
Ding? U-Launcher.
Ich mein. Wir können's. Wir können's ja mal
ausprobieren.
Was. Was irgendeiner im Chat.
Alter.
Was ist denn hier immer los?
Please. Was wollen diese Dinger?
Was wollen diese Dinger mir immer installieren?
Okay. Das sind. Das sind Make
Dependencies. Die kann man.
Wir haben mal nen Snapshot gemacht.
Ui. Guck mal.
Abt hätte noch nicht mal angefangen jetzt.
Pac-Man und so.
Das flutscht einfach immer richtig.
Richtig zackig. U-Launcher.
Okay. Lull.
Ah ja. Okay.
Öh. References.
Gibt's da. Color Theme. Elementary Dark.
Reloaded schon mal
nicht automatisch. Schau mal.
Cringe.
Packt rum beim Fenster Resizen. Mann.
Sag mal. Gibt's da auch. Gibt's zur Abwechslung
auch mal irgendwie gescheite Software hier?
Guck mal.
Packt rum beim Fenster Resizen.
Wahrscheinlich ist da.
Wahrscheinlich weil sie irgendwie
Wayland Support
geil finden und X nicht mehr richtig
unterstützen oder. Was ist das?
Shortcuts.
Ah ja. References.
Pod Key.
Control Space. Okay.
Brauch ich nicht.
Aber eins muss man ihnen zugute
halten.
Es sieht zumindest schon mal besser aus.
Als
das andere.
Es startet halt einfach.
Dafür hab ich da kein Clipboard Manager
Integration und sowas.
Ne ne. Ich werd bei RoFi bleiben und
im Zweifelsfall. Leute.
Im Zweifelsfall mach ich einfach
mir ein eigenes Theme.
Weil dazu brauchst du ja.
Realistisch betrachtet musst du
drei Farben angeben und es ist fertig.
Was ist das? Deep Learning.
Add in. Moment. Das hat
Extensions. Das was?
Deep.
Ach Translate.
Translate Text using
Deeple. Clipboard.
Clip.
Copy Snippets to your Clipboard.
Clipboard.
Gibt's da auch. Gibt's da vielleicht irgendwas wo ich
einfach nur Text rein bekomme?
Green Clip oder so?
Angeblich findet der
Clipboard irgendwie auf der Seite. Ich seh's jetzt nicht.
Ich will auf jeden Fall da ein
Clipboard Manager drinne haben.
Ah Clipboard Manager. Zeig mal her.
Integrated with
Clipman Clipstar
Copy Q G Paste.
Okay. Aber das sind
wieder irgendwelche Third Unbeater Plugins.
Okay. Zeig mal her.
Add Extension.
Zack.
Deeple.
Add Extension. Add.
Okay. On.
G Paste Clipman
Auto Clipstar.
Gut. Kann man
irgendwas auswählen?
Okay. So wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht erkennen.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier kopiere.
Clipboard. Ne. Deep L.
Ne. Wie muss ich das jetzt machen wenn ich
da was translaten will?
Ist mir das vielleicht erst konf...
Ist es gecrashed gerade?
Was muss ich da jetzt machen um es zu...
Ha! Lies doch erst mal
die Git-Seiten. Ne.
TR. Okay.
Ich hab's schon mal
zum Crashen gebracht. Schon mal nice.
Crashed. Ah!
Pip 3 Install.
Okay. Ich muss erst mal
Python install...
Jetzt hat das auch nicht Copy
Pasted man. Also was muss
ich machen? Extension?
Pip 3. Ich hab gar kein...
Jetzt muss ich erst mal 30 Millionen
Pip.
Da ist das Package davon. Python, Pip.
Okay. Jetzt saue ich mir
das System noch ein bisschen weiter zu.
Okay.
Ist es jetzt installiert?
Ne. Ist schon das Richtige.
U-Launcher.
TR.
Ach jetzt muss ich in
API Key eintippen. Ah. Okay.
Copy.
Copy vom Clipboard.
Ähm. Und wie benutze ich
den Clipboard Manager?
Copy Word. C.
Copy from Clipboard History.
Ah ja. Hier.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz okay.
Muss ich sagen.
Kommt man auch mit klar.
Muss ich halt dran gewöhnen.
C.
Okay. Ich schreibe C und dann
kannst du hier was suchen.
Warum nicht? Ja.
Ist auch okay. Kann man benutzen.
Was sagt denn
Rofi vs. U-Launcher?
Was sagt Reddit dazu?
Your favorite
Launcher. Reddit. Was sagt Reddit?
Das interessiert mich wieder brennend.
Was sagt Reddit dazu?
Okay.
Toller Hintergrund.
PipoFatTime.
Ist Borgia auch noch ein extra Launcher?
Oder ist das irgendein
Meme, was ich nicht checke?
Ach wegen Burger.
Ich meine ich hätte das auch für den Launcher.
gehalten. Mittlerweile weiß der wirklich
eigentlich... Flow Launcher?
Eigentlich sehr clever.
Der hat einen Post gemacht über
U-Launcher und will eigentlich nur mit seinem Desktop flexen.
Ist Albert nicht irgendein
Mac OS Ding?
Ne.
Sag mal wie viele gibt es denn von diesen komischen
Launchern eigentlich?
C++
gleich Sackfall.
Fast and Flexible
Keyboard Launcher.
Wie viel
an dem Zeug gibt es denn?
A sophisticated
Standalone Keyboard
Launcher. Komm ich habe einen
Snapshot. Ich kann alles installieren und dann wieder
runter hauen.
Direkt weg. Genau.
Jetzt erstmal C++ kompilieren
und dann direkt wieder Sackfall
wie dieses Terminal.
Komplett zufrieden mit meinem neuen PC. Ja.
Ich hatte noch nicht einen Crash. Das Ding ist
wirklich super stable.
Und schnell as fuck.
Ich probiere komische Sachen für
Linux aus, die der Chat mir empfiehlt.
Beziehungsweise wir um
5 Wecken drauf kommen.
Borga. Hamborga.
Ok. Reddit ist sich auch nicht
so einig.
Was zum Teufel ist Fussel?
Warum gibt es 1000 solcher Sachen?
Alter. Könnt ihr nicht mal
vielleicht 5. Ach das ist für
Wayland. Ok. 5 machen das reicht.
Und dann
ist gut.
Lol. Ok.
Es kompiliert noch. Mal gucken.
Ah siehste. Das ist nur
Single Threaded. Da war Rust aber
Blazingly faster.
Was sind die neuen Specs?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen PC.
Viel zu teuer.
Ok. Während er
kompiliert können wir es uns zusammen angucken.
Und mir kann noch mal einer abgehen auf
meinen neuen Rechner.
Was für ein OS Type? 64 Bit
Linux. Das reicht. Also.
Was haben wir hier drinne? Guckte mal.
2 Terabyte.
Achso. Ja gut. Das ist die SSD. Ich habe ja mittlerweile
deutlich mehr SSDs drin. Ich habe meine alten
SSD alle zusammen gesammelt und da rein gepappt.
13900K.
64G RAM.
4090 RTX.
Ein Mainboard.
Ein Kontaktframe.
Für die Wasserkühlung. Ein fettes Gehäuse.
Eine Wasserkühlung. Und ein ordentliches
Netzteil. So sieht es aus.
Boah der kompiliert
ja wieder das halbe Internet hier.
So. Bin gerade neu bei
der Ryder IDE. Sehr gute
Wahl.
Ist das System Namespace standardmäßig
importiert wenn man neue Projekte anlegt?
Das hat mit Ryder nichts zu tun.
Die Projekte
die dort angelegt werden
sind das was die .NET CLI
anlegt. Und ja die normalen
die Projekte die
.NET CLI anlegt ist
standardmäßig ein Hello World
mit glaube ich 3-4 Imports drinne.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
Moment ist es abgebrochen?
Moment ist es beim komp...
Ne oder?
Ne es hat. Ach ne hier unten war das ja.
Ok wie heißt das Ding?
Jetzt jetzt Albert. Ok.
Sieht schon mal
richtig. Oh sieht schon mal richtig
oldschool aus das Interface.
Theme, Spotlight, Dark.
Alles klar. Ok.
Appsearch.
Also das Ding durchsucht
weder Clipboard noch
irgendwas anderes.
Files.
Ok. Extensions.
Nix da.
Es gibt Extensions und es gibt
Plugins. Ok.
Plugins. Das ist alles?
Ok. Applications.
Chrome interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Ok es gibt schon mal keine
Clipboard
Integration. So wie es
aussieht.
Schon mal doof.
Ach ne Copy Snippets to the Clipboard.
Snippets heißt das. Ok.
Kann man das jetzt. Ach hier.
Snippets. Ne Moment.
Ne ne ne. Ok es gibt
tatsächlich keine Clipboard. Das ist aber auch schon
sieht auch schon ziemlich oldschool aus.
Ok probieren wir mal aus. Zack.
Ah ja hier Firefox.
Ne das
gefällt mir nicht das Ding.
Weiß nicht. Aber das ist
irgendwie. So ohne
Clipboard. Clipboard History
Feature.
Gibt es nicht.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Ja da ist ein Plugin.
Das ist halt. Leute Plugin
Architekturen schön und gut.
Das blöde
ist nur, dass
dort halt die Maintainer
öfters mal wegrennen bei den Plugins.
Also ich finde so eine Anwendung muss schon
eine gute Core Funktionalität
mitbringen.
Sonst.
Ich werde bei Rofi bleiben.
Rofi kannst du easy
Sachen reinpipen.
Ich weiß nicht. Kannst du bei U-Launcher einfach Sachen reinpipen?
So nach dem Motto Echo.
Ich weiß nicht.
U-Launcher
Standed in.
Weil dann wäre das easy. Da könnte man
da alles mit reinhauen.
Ah Leute ich weiß nicht. Also.
Ich glaube
ich werde bei Rofi mit so einem billig
Billig Custom Theme bleiben.
Und fertig.
Ich bin echt.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht was ich da mehr
von brauchen würde.
Ich meine ich kann.
Ich meine ich habe einen Clipboard
Manager. Zack.
Ich meine vielleicht werde ich die Farbe ein bisschen anpassen.
So Clipboard Manager.
Und einen Application
Launcher. Fertig.
Mehr benutze ich nicht. Vielleicht ist es noch
Emojis. Okay. Wisst ihr was
wir machen? Wir machen das ganz einfach.
Wir machen das ganz einfach.
Ja.
Home Max Local Share
Themes Slate.
Mein viel steht ja da nicht drin.
Wir reden hier um ein paar
Zeilen. So.
Wo muss
das hin?
Home Local Share
Rofi Themes.
Das Ding wieder weg. Yes.
Rofi.
Komm wieder. Ruf.
Und.
Wo ist er?
29. Zack.
Gib ihm.
Rofi Show D Menu.
Okay.
Was war es nochmal? Wow. Wow. Wow. Das will ich hier nicht
einfügen. Less. Okay.
Config Rofi. Ne. Wo?
Oh Gott. Alter. Please.
Local
Share
Ach.
Das gibt es da wieder nicht.
Mkdir Local Share
Mkdir Minus P
Local Share Rofi
Themes war es glaube ich.
Genau. So.
Und dann
Slate Punkt Rasi.
Zack. Zack. Rein.
Und jetzt
Steam
Steam Selector
Zack. Easy.
Das war es.
Can't read Config. Ja.
Juckt mich nicht. Weißt du? Easy.
Schon funktioniert.
So. Und jetzt kopieren wir noch das andere
rüber.
Ruf.
Und dann ist gut.
Wir müssen es ja nicht unbedingt.
Komm mal. Top. Kannst du nicht beschweren.
Oder?
Die Schrift ist anders.
Ich brauche nicht Hack. Ich brauche
Hack Mono.
Glaube ich, dass es stimmt.
Warum sieht das jetzt anders aus?
Warum sieht das jetzt
anders aus? Sekunde. Sekunde.
Hack Nerd Font.
Ja, aber das sollte doch keinen großen Unterschied machen, oder?
Wobei, das sieht nicht anders aus.
Das sieht eigentlich
Ok. Firefox. Haben wir bei
beidem. Wir brauchen mal was zum
vergleichen. Das ist eine andere
Font. Die ist. Die ist. Das ist eine andere
Font. Das sind
die Spaces. Die Spaces sind
anders.
Guck mal. Das ist
eine ganz andere Font.
Du hast es im Westterm umgestellt.
Ja und?
Also jetzt.
Ich habe doch hier.
Das ist eine andere Font.
Segmentation Font.
Ähm.
Ok. FC Lists
Hack Nerd Font
Mono. Vielleicht muss ich. Vielleicht muss ich so
eingeben. Ah.
Viel besser.
Jet Brains.
Toolbox. Ganz ehrlich?
Ich war.
Meine Frage. Wir haben jetzt sehr viele verschiedene
Anwendungen ausprobiert.
Einfach so als Launcher.
Und auch Themes. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Mir gefällt
meine Config hier, die ich hatte
immer noch am besten. Das ist einfach
total idiotensicher. Du hast ein Fenster.
Gibst dein Zeug ein. Startest und ist gut.
Ich meine. Mehr willst du ja nicht.
Ja. Bam. Fertig.
Oh.
Das allerwichtigste Leute.
Wir brauchen natürlich noch Neo Fetch.
Ohne Neo Fetch geht ja hier gar nichts.
Btop.
Ja. Btop ist
für die ganz coolen Leute.
Die so viele Informationen
haben wollen, dass sie gar nicht mehr
durchblicken.
Ich meine. Seriously.
Wir blicken hier noch durch was da gerade passiert.
Man kann auch
Control P.
Ne. What the.
Menus. Sieht aus wie Doom.
Options.
Themes.
Hat das Ding. Alter.
Das ist total übertrieben.
Uh. Mein Auge. Alter.
Btop. Ja.
Tomorrow Night.
Adapter.
Okay.
One Dark.
Auch okay.
Excellent. So. Wo kann man
den Refresh.
Wo stellt man ein wie oft er Refreshed.
Das ist mir schon wieder.
Update Intervall.
Das Update Intervall muss runter.
Update Intervall kommt auf 100 Millisekunden.
Bam. In your face.
Ja. Ein bisschen was tut hier auch.
Ah.
Und jetzt. Machen wir mal ein bisschen
Last und gucken ob das
funktioniert.
Echo 2 hoch.
Das da. Nach
BC. Wie. What.
BC not found. Was ist denn das.
Äh. 16.
Ich meine wir können auch.
Wie heißt das Ding. Es gibt ja auch so ein Programm
wo man einfach nur.
Terminal UI Stress Test. Moment.
Was.
Terminal Based CPU
Stress Test and Monitoring
Utility.
Excellent. Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
SS Stress.
Okay.
Modes. Monitor.
Stress. Äh.
Und wie startet man das jetzt.
Ach Moment. Der ist schon. Der ist schon.
Okay.
CPU Auslastung.
Okay. Btop.
Jetzt mal wieder überhaupt nicht geschissen.
Zeigt irgendeinen Müll an.
20% CPU Auslastung.
Htop.
Htop checkt es sofort.
Vielleicht muss ich bei Btop.
Die.
Options.
Vielleicht muss ich den Intervallen. Leute.
Mein Rechner laggt. Alter. Laggt das Stream.
Laggt das Stream. Sollte.
Sollte eigentlich nicht. Ich meine ich hab noch genug.
Ne.
Ich hab noch genug freie CPU Kerne.
Update Intervall.
100 machen wir mal. Okay.
Ach hier oben. Doch hier oben checkt das doch 100%.
Aber hier unten checkt das nicht.
Okay. Vielleicht. Wisst ihr was sein kann.
Dass das hier unten.
Ach guck mal.
Hier kann man sogar scrollen drin.
Das hier unten sind 100% insgesamt.
Und das hier ist pro Core.
Das ist mein neuer Rechner. Ja.
Also das hier unten zusammen sind 100%.
Und hier oben hast du es pro Core.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hab nix gesagt. Ist wirklich.
Ist doch ganz gut.
8x20% 100. Richtig.
Menu.
Was hat das noch für Dinger.
Dracula.
Tokio Storm Dusk.
Tokio Night.
Default.
Lassen wir mal Default da.
Okay. Wir sehen jetzt aber hier ordentlich die Auslastung.
Kennt ihr eine gute Methode
um von Windows 7
Remote Befehle auf einen
Windows XP Rechner auszuführen.
Äh.
Sowas wie SSH willst du quasi.
Für Windows.
Also du kannst über RDP bestimmt auch einzelne Programme starten.
Telnet.
Wenn gar nix geht.
Aber gibt es nicht SSH auch für Windows.
Und wenn es sein.
Mach halt Sync Win drauf.
Ich kenn mich mit Windows nicht aus.
Ja gut Temperature hab ich nicht.
Leute.
Was sehe ich hier.
Frequency und das ist die Auslastung.
Okay.
Eigentlich gar nicht übel.
Ach hier kann man Plus und Minus drücken.
Ah man muss gar nicht in die Settings.
Man kann einfach Plus und Minus drücken.
Alles klar.
Oh.
Terminal size too small.
Das ist schonmal cringe.
Stress.
Ne ich brauch keine Notifications.
Kann man das sogar per Maus anklicken?
Oho.
Was ist das Advanced man.
Also was er unten.
Er sich hier auch unten zusammen rechnet.
Keine Ahnung.
Na gut das könnte.
Das könnte.
Das könnte ein Hyperthreading liegen.
Unter der.
Wobei ich hab ja gar kein Hyperthreading hier drin auf.
Alter dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Komisches Zeug macht er da.
Egal abbrechen.
Stress.
Kein Stress.
Ähm. Mal gucken. Mal gucken ob das Netzwerkübertragung.
Das kann ich ihn mal schnell curlen.
Ubuntu ISO.
Irgendwas fettes.
Curl Speedtest oder sowas.
Ja 10G File.
Von wo denn?
Gibt es irgendwo da was schönes großes?
Hetzner Testfile.
Ja.
10G. Perfekt.
Copy Link.
Ah ok.
Klutscht.
Und.
Ja.
Ok dann checkts.
Er checkts.
Geschwindigkeit wird gedrosselt anscheinend.
Es geht immer weiter runter.
Was ist das?
Wird wahrscheinlich nicht an Hetzner liegen oder?
Schwankt.
Ja aber das checkt das.
Liegt bestimmt an Vodafone wahrscheinlich.
Ah ne hab ich noch gar nicht drauf.
Ok.
Ja haben wir heute schon wieder ordentlich sein.
Also.
Mit der Rofi Geschichte bin ich ja tatsächlich nicht so glücklich geworden.
Das erscheint mir wirklich am simpelsten hier.
Noch cooler wäre es, wenn ich gar kein extra Theme bräuchte.
Sondern direkt die Color hier angeben kann.
Kann man die Color direkt auf der Kommandozeile angeben?
Das wäre natürlich noch viel besser.
Dann brauche ich nämlich gar keine komische Config Datei.
Deran Categories.
Zeug man ja.
Gibt da irgendwas drinnen wie Color?
Ne.
Oh.
Ne anscheinend nicht.
Ah wie viele Optionen hat denn das Ding?
Du du du du.
Ja.
Ah es hat ja extrem viele.
Options.
Enable Hover Effect.
Da kannst du ja wirklich.
Dich dumm und dämlich konfigurieren bei.
Ah was auch immer.
Interessant.
Ja Leute.
Ich hab mich schon konfiguriert heute.
Das reicht.
Das reicht mir.
Wie du was sortierst?
Was willst du machen?
In H-Top kannst du sortieren.
In H-Top kannst du glaube ich F6 drücken.
Oder so.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was du meinst.
Also was.
Ich kann dir mal zeigen was du machen kannst.
In H-Top. Ach du meinst jetzt in B-Top.
Keine Ahnung ich verwende B-Top eigentlich nicht.
Ich würde sagen H-Top.
H-Top ist so ein.
Ich weiß.
Ganz ehrlich.
Das hat alles an Features was ich haben will.
CPU Auslastung.
Und neuerdings hat es sogar Disk IO.
B-Top ist zwar an sich nice.
Von der Idee her.
Aber so bloated irgendwie.
Da muss man sich erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Außerdem muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Man kann hier auch unterschiedliche Presets durchschalten.
Wie das ganze aussehen soll.
Du willst die Prozesse sortieren.
Wie könnte das funktionieren?
So schon mal nicht.
Per Core.
Was fällt das nach links rechts geht.
Und dann macht es was.
CPU Idle.
Memory User.
Threads.
Command.
Achja okay das ist tatsächlich ganz einfach.
Pit.
Wenn man das weiß ist es ganz einfach.
Was soll ich aus.
B-P-Top.
Ist das nicht ähm.
Ported nach C++ ist quasi das gleiche.
Nur in C++.
Also B-Pi-Top.
Ist das gleiche.
Nur blazingly fast written in Rust.
Ey nicht wirklich.
Was das für ein Betriebssystem ist.
Arch by the way.
Wie es im Titel steht.
Arch Linux.
Weil einzig wahre.
Jeder Linux User.
Früher oder später.
Muss bei Arch Linux landen.
Neo Fetch.
Bam.
Da gibt es nicht wirklich viel zu sehen.
Außer das es eine VM Kiste ist.
Und Rest Default Themes.
Neo Fetch.
Oh ist P-Fetch die coolere Variante?
Nee P-Fetch gibt es nur.
Einfach nur weil es geht.
Einfach mal angucken.
Okay P-Fetch.
Ah das ist in klein.
Ich bin immer begeistert.
Das es dafür.
So viele tausend Sachen gibt immer.
Wie zufrieden.
Das Terminal ist richtig nice.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich hab die ersten 15 Minuten.
Weil es wirklich scheiß Default Settings hat.
Habe ich gedacht.
So ein Mist wer verwendet sowas.
Das ist das beste Terminal was ich seit Jahren verwendet habe.
Das ist richtig gut.
Also du kannst alles konfigurieren.
Du kannst alles mitmachen.
Du kannst sogar.
Pass mal auf.
Ähm.
Du kannst sogar sowas hier machen.
Guck mal.
In der Konsole man.
Also besser geht es ja nur wirklich nicht mehr.
Wenigstens gestart auf GitHub.
Nee. Bin nicht eingeloggt.
ImageCat ist übrigens.
Kein Programm.
Das ist ein Alias.
Das ist ein Alias auf Westterm.
Äh.
ImageCat.
Und dann hier.
Downloads Anime Excited.
Nur das ich die Bilder.
Ein bisschen gescaled habe für das Terminal.
Das benutzt unter der Haube.
Habe ich gelesen.
Das iTerm Image Protokoll.
Leider hat Westterm keine Save Restore Funktion.
Ja.
Kannst du nicht einfach ein Skript machen.
Was dir nach dem Reboot.
Die Sachen so hinstellt wie du willst.
Oder möchtest du keine.
Festen fixen Sessions starten.
Sondern du möchtest quasi das.
Einfrieren wie du es.
Vom Reboot hattest und dann wieder aufmachen.
Inklusive Buffer und allem.
Oder wie.
Permanentes Scroll Back.
Okay.
Jeder. Jeder.
Jeder wie er am besten.
Arbeiten kann.
Jetzt nicht so ganz.
Aber wie gesagt.
Jeder wie er am besten arbeiten kann.
Also ich habe überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Wenn ich das jetzt schließe.
Dann ist es halt weg.
Und dann.
Wo ist das Problem.
Dann macht man das Tab halt wieder auf.
Ich habe P-Fetch ohne.
Quatsch habe ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe P-Fetch installiert.
Ich habe ja P-Fetch auch entfernt.
Ja ja.
Gif in der Konsole ist schon.
Ist schon ein krasses Feature.
Oder?
Was war denn unsere.
Unsere ASCII Quarium muss funktionieren.
Tiling im Terminal.
Es darf nicht crachen wenn man Tab drückt.
Es darf nicht Resize abkacken.
Emojis sollen gehen.
Emojis sollen sich nicht overlappen.
Tmax Funktionalität.
Und Bilder im Terminal.
All das kann Westterm.
Und ist richtig super zu konfigurieren.
Also ich muss sagen das ist das beste Terminal.
Weil ich es seit langem ausprobiert habe.
Achso ja und Hollywood muss natürlich drauf.
Ganz wichtig.
Ne muss nicht drauf.
Nerdphones habe ich schon installiert.
Aber ich habe noch keine Custom Leiste.
Oder Polybar.
Ich finde man muss es mit der Konfig auch nicht übertreiben.
Ich Resize die Fenster nicht.
Wobei.
Ich mache ein zweites Fenster höchstens auf.
Okay damit Reflow funktioniert.
Muss ich ja erstmal testen.
Wie es aussieht wenn.
Okay der reflowt einfach gar nicht.
Oder macht man.
Interessiert den einfach gar nicht so.
Ach doch hier.
Das funktioniert.
Das scheinen die ganz gut hinzukriegen.
Zu reflowen.
Ganz ehrlich Starship ist auch ein cooler Prom.
Und wenn ich zum Beispiel in .NET Repo wechsle, kriege ich hier angezeigt, dass ich auf dem Masterbranch bin, keine Comments und sogar welches Framework das Projekt benutzt.
Und wenn ich uncommittete Sachen drin habe, ist dann ein Fragezeichen. Also ganz cool.
Was machen wir? Wir verwenden das im Stream anstelle der normalen Streaming-VM.
Also so gut wie alles, was wir hier im Stream machen an Technik-Kram, machen wir unter Linux.
Das machen wir jetzt ab jetzt hier drin.
Und nicht, also, okay, vielleicht verwenden wir die alte schon noch ab und zu mal.
Das machen wir ab jetzt hier drin und nicht mal in der alten VM.
Was benutzt du für eine Starship-Prompt-Config?
0815 Default.
Default mit Bracket-Symbols oder irgendwie sowas.
Nein, die Qt-VM habe ich nicht umgezogen.
Die brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Wetter in Hessen. Okay, Moment.
Wirklich?
Zeig mal, zeig mal.
Das ist Sixhead.
Sixheader-Time.
Mein Terminal hat ja auch Sixhead-Support.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Okay, Moment.
Dann braucht man immer noch, dann braucht man immer noch, Moment.
Rare Parrot Curl.
Nee, wie ging das?
Moment, Curl.
Parrot.live.
So, jetzt haben wir alles.
Ganz wichtig, dass sowas, sowas braucht man.
Ask Equarium, das ist selbstverständlich.
Und sogar das Farbschema angepasst, dass man alles sieht.
Schon nicht unwichtig.
Das kenne ich.
Ja, ja.
Da gibt's, das gibt's auch in zig, in zig, in zig verschiedenen,
in zig verschiedenen Programmiersprachen.
Leute, die das, die das nachgebaut haben.
Nur vom Feinsten.
So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Ach nee, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Aber hier unten, hier unten sieht man's.
Also die, die, die beste, die beste Kombination,
die beste Kombination ist immer noch das Ask Equarium nach LOLCAT.
So sieht das wahrscheinlich aus, wenn du vorher die im Frankfurter,
vor der Hauptbahnhof irgendwas geholt hast.
Curl spielt ja im Terminal nicht wirklich was ab.
Das, das rendert halt Zeichen da rein.
Und der Webserver liefert dem, liefert Curl Zeichen mit passenden, äh, ASCII Escape,
nee, ANSI Escape Sequenzen, was die Shell versteht.
Dazu kannst du auch machen.
Normaler, ich meine nur, weil normalerweise HTML bei einem Web-Request zurückkommt,
muss es ja nicht sein.
Muss ja nicht zwangsläufig gültiges HTML sein, was dazu kommt.
Kannst ja alles mögliche streamen über ein HTTP-Request.
Muss ja nicht, muss ja nicht HTML sein.
Das ist normalerweise HTML, aber muss es nicht.
So, jetzt haben wir die, die, die, die wichtigen Sachen.
Aber das mit dem Wetter ist cool.
Wetter.
Ist zu geil, Alter.
Kann man auch Frankfurt machen?
Frankfurt?
Nee, not found.
Woher weiß ich denn?
Woher weiß ich denn, was der da?
Wer überhaupt kann?
Also, woher, woher weiß ich, was ich da, was ich da eingeben kann?
Hanau.
Nee, nee, Hanau will ich nicht.
Ich will nach Frankfurt.
Warum ist es einmal V2 und einmal V3?
Oder muss ich das groß oder klein schreiben?
Ja, C-Matrix ist, ist klar.
Warum gibt es, warum gibt es Frankfurt nicht?
Your Region.
Okay, das funktioniert wirklich nur mit Region aktuell anscheinend.
Das ist aber auch, das ist aber auch mal eine richtig coole Idee, oder?
Ja, Image Support, Alter.
Lull.
Und was ist bei V2?
Ah.
Da gibt es so ein komisches, da gibt es aber bestimmt Frankfurt.
Ah, ja, ja.
Das ist, das ist schon cool, oder?
Dass es im Terminal so funktioniert?
Und was ist V1?
Ah, okay.
Okay, V1 ist quasi so ein, so ein, äh, so eine Vorhersage.
Das ist mir, ich finde das so geil, wie, wie kreativ die Leute sind, dass die auf sowas kommen.
Nee, V4 gibt das, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Nee.
Wird es gleich, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich V8 mache.
V0.
Ja, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wobei, so wie du es kopiert hast, kann ich das machen.
Das ist kein Problem.
In Quotes.
Ohne Quotes ist problematisch.
Nee, wie war das?
Hessen, Hessen.
Okay, was ist der Unterschied?
Zwischen?
Wunderbar.
Ah, okay, das ist, das ist quasi so eine Vorhersage.
Evening.
V2 zeigt dir quasi, V2 zeigt dir quasi so den gesamten Tag über an.
Aber da fehlt mir jetzt die Uhrzeit dabei.
Oder, was, was, was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Das sind mehrere Tage, gell?
Das sind mehrere Tage, so vormittags, nachmittags und so.
Es ist nicht so einfach.
Ach, das hier ist die Uhrzeit.
Okay, machen wir mal Frankfurt.
Ist das, ist das hier, was ist das hier?
Irgendein Niederschlag?
Niederschlag-Wahrscheinlichkeit, oder?
Nee, das sind, das sind vier Tage, würde ich sagen, oder?
6, 12, 18 Uhr.
Also drei Tage sogar.
Dreieinhalb Tage.
Drei Tage.
Heimsohn Los Angeles?
Okay, ich muss, ich muss Hessen.
Ich muss Hessen machen.
Los Angeles?
Was will der Typ von mir, Alter?
Aber V3 ist cool mit dem Bild.
Aber ohne, ohne, ohne geht's auch nicht.
Ah, nee, jetzt geht's.
Hä?
Guck mal.
Jetzt haben wir Hessen.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich, wo wir gerade sind.
So 21 Uhr 44.
Ah, oder?
Oder?
Ist, ist das, wo wir gerade hier sind?
Was, ist das heute?
Was da?
Ich vermute mal, das ist heute.
Ach, nee, das ist Windgeschwindigkeit.
Ach, nee, heute ist ja auch der 22.
Ach, das ist, das ist heute.
Das ist nicht das Datum.
Hier, das sind einfach nur drei Tage.
Das, das hat, es hat was.
Wobei ich das auch wirklich, das finde ich auch sehr nice.
Ups.
Wie, wie sich, sichseln.
Das finde ich auch sehr nice.
Also ohne Scheiß, das in Kombination damit ist vollkommen, ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Hier hast du, hier hast du einfach drei Tagesübersicht.
Kann ich zum Beispiel gucken, okay, morgens ist es, äh, morgens ist es noch ziemlich kalt.
Und, ähm, tja, wolkig.
Und dann, V3.
Und dann kann ich mir noch eine Karte angucken.
Ich finde, ich finde es, ich finde es cool.
Ah, weil ich schon, ich wollte schon immer wissen, wie es in Hofgeismar ist.
Wow, was?
Moment, das ist ein Prometheus-Exporter.
Seriously?
Lustig.
Man kriegt, man kriegt das sogar als Prometheus-Exporter geliefert, das Wetter.
Das ist schon nice.
Jason ist J1.
Gibt es auch Jammel?
Oh.
Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht.
Woher weiß man, was es da für Formate gibt?
Interessant, interessant.
Aber es ist cool.
Es ist, es ist, also ich bin wirklich immer wieder erstaunt, wie kreativ die Leute sind.
Ja, weil theoretisch kann man sich das jetzt als Alias einfach in die Schell hauen.
Ja.
Dass man jetzt sagt, oh, das macht man da rein.
Aber irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich habe aktuell nur eine Bash.
Deswegen, es bringt es eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Also jetzt irgendwie Alias Wetter.
Oh, Curl das.
Und Curl V1.
Und dann kriege ich eine coole Übersicht.
Das gebe ich einfach, mache ich mal das Terminal schnell zu, um das Neue zu sourcen.
V2 macht Nerdfonts.
Okay, das probieren wir gleich aus.
Hier Format.
Format V2.
Ne, das haben wir doch gerade schon.
Das, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Die Ausgabe.
Hm, das ist gleich wie V2 vorne.
Jetzt kann ich sagen Wetter.
Und ich kriege die zwei Sachen.
Okay, das ist natürlich doof.
Was, V2D?
Ne, V.
Das, das hat, das.
Ach hier.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt mach das nicht mit Emojis.
Jetzt mach das genauer mit, mit gepatchten Fonts.
Die Typen sind wirklich äußerst kreativ, muss man sagen, auf sowas zu kommen.
Das ist schon cool.
Hat schon, hat schon was.
Jetzt kann man es auch ohne Emojis rein mit Nerdfonts sich angucken.
So, ich kann jetzt machen Wetter.
Oder ich kann Wetter, ne, nach Less pipen.
Wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ein bisschen zu viel für eine Terminal-Seite.
Man, man könnte das natürlich nach Lolcat pipen.
Dann sieht es natürlich besonders toll aus, ja.
Format, was?
Format 4.
Ah, okay.
Da siehst du, wie es aktuell ist, ja.
Aber wie es aktuell ist, gucke ich einfach in meinen Home Assistant in die Wetterstation.
Easy.
Man könnte jetzt.
Man könnte ja für.
Für einen schnellen Überblick.
Könnte man einfach sagen, hier ist Sleep 2.
Wetter.
Okay, aha, aha, aha.
Und wie sieht es dann aus?
Oder, oder einen Read oder so einbauen.
Aber ich mach, ich mach mal eher so.
Wetter.
Ah, okay.
Hm, plus 1, alles klar.
Dann warte ich kurz.
Dann kriege ich auch noch die Übersicht.
Eigentlich, eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich meine, es gibt es auch noch als PNG oder was?
Alter, die, sag mal.
Gibt es irgendein Format, was sie nicht haben?
Okay, Curl, Pipe nach Westerm Image Cat.
Jetzt wird es aber.
Aber was kommt mir mit 1 noch raus?
Ah, da sind dann verschiedene.
Aha, aha.
Und mit 2 kommt wahrscheinlich dann die gesamte, die nächsten paar Tage.
Ach nee, da sind 2.
Ach so.
Die nächsten 2 Tage.
Es ist schon, es ist schon äußerst advanced.
Es ist schon äußerst advanced, Wetter, Wetter, Feuersage auf, um, toll.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, warum sollte ich jetzt mal.
Es ist, es ist schon ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge, oder?
Ich lasse mir was in ASCII-Dings zum PNG rendern, um es dann mit Image Cat als Bild in meinem eigentlich textbasierten Interface anzuzeigen.
Also, dann, dann bleib, dann bleib ich doch lieber, bleib ich doch lieber dabei.
Lass danach die ASCII-gerenderte Vorschau.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Also, das war's.
Hat was, das gefällt mir.
Jetzt kann ich immer kurz nachgucken, was wir für ein Wetter haben.
Auch in Hofgeismar.
Kann man Skalierung wählen?
Ja, kannst du machen.
Du kannst sagen, ich zeig, ich zeig's dir.
Machen wir jetzt noch schnell.
Hier.
Äh, du kannst sagen, nach Western, Image Cat.
Nee, äh, wie kriegt man da jetzt Standard, Standard in was rein?
Mit, mit.
Mit Minus hintendran?
Okay, ich mein, ich mein, wir können, wir können so machen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Aber eben hat das doch auch funktioniert.
Westerm ist richtig Poggers.
Richtig Poggers.
Ich glaub, das kann man damit gar nicht anzeigen.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, das kann man damit gar nicht anzeigen.
Probieren wir mal kurz aus.
Machen wir mal WGET.
Error not found, okay.
Hä?
Wie, was ist not found?
Kann man nicht.
Aber ich kann auch Chip machen.
Äh, Curl, Blubb, ah ja, funktioniert doch.
Und jetzt?
Westerm, Image Cat, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Also das ist, das ist irgendein Special Format.
Also mit Westerm selbst, also wenn man ein PNG oder sowas hat, das kann man resizen.
Das anscheinend nicht.
Da könnte man zum Beispiel installieren, oder wie hieß das?
Das ist ein Image, das ist ein Terminal Image Viewer.
Da kann man zum Beispiel sowas.
Ach nee, geht nicht.
Ah, ich dachte, der kann direkt.
Aber Moment, wenn's mal ein Terminal kann, dann kann ich's doch wahrscheinlich einfach
ketten.
Ha!
Hä?
Kann ich's einfach ketten?
Aber dann kann ich's nicht resizen.
Dann kann ich's nicht resizen an der Stelle.
Na gut.
Weg damit.
Also, vielleicht, vielleicht haben die ja irgendwelche Optionen für, ähm, with oder
so.
Haben die irgendeine API-Doc?
Wetter in ARPIDOC?
Nein, ARpi?
A3.
Weil irgendwie muss man's ja rausbekommen?
Help.
V3.
Ne.
Was...
Curl?
Wetter.in-slash-help.
Ne.
Doppelpunkt-Help.
Ah!
Sixhead-Time.
Aber das ist das, was wir gerade offen hatten.
Ich wollte die ARPI-Version und sowas, sowas sehen.
Aber das steht da, steht da nicht drinne.
Weil, vielleicht, vielleicht hätte man das ja resizen können.
Möglich, möglich wär's
Trotzdem, sehr coole, sehr coole Sache
Also die Leute sind extrem
Sixhead, die sich das ausdenken
Gut, jetzt waren wir aber echt, Schluss, reicht jetzt
Für heute, genug gebastelt
Wir sehen uns morgen
Bis denn
Macht's gut, see you
Badgittime
Muss ich nicht eigentlich noch reacten?
Reacten auf die Reaction?
Aber das machen wir heute nicht
Ich
Ich erzähl euch dann schon seit vier Streams
Dass wir uns das angucken wollen
Aber ich hab heute im Discord gelesen
So viel Interessantes war da gar nicht
Okay, wir sehen uns, bis denn, macht's gut
See you